good morning
we might be a little light on the
attendance today but we'll motor on
so we do have enough people there one
two three
okay great
um okay so we will now open the public
hearing on House Bill 445 and the chair
will recognize representative ulery to
introduce the bill although I will need
a pink card from you
thank you madam chair for the record my
name is Jordan ulery Hillsborough 13 in
the town of Hudson
um this past summer I sat on a uh
commission to discuss some of the issues
surrounding uh oplc I think I finally
got those acronym down
um
in that we came up with a uh
series of issues I won't say problems
because they they're surmountable uh
issues uh faced by oplc one of which was
the mandatory requirement in current law
that any excess funds is are lapsed into
the general fund at the end of the uh
biennium
which means that there's Gap years that
exist because they've got access funds
so the excess funds have to be lapsed
back into the general fund
so
one of the ways to continue their
process in order to make sure that they
have money for investigators when people
make allegations against licensed
individuals uh so that they can continue
to operate their various operations
including
issuing new licenses and organizing the
board
extra funds are required
they estimate that it costs them around
three to five million dollars uh every
year to fill in these funds therefore
we've decided the the commission decided
we split up different tasks you will
notice throughout the calendar uh
several different bills that are going
to be coming up including one which is a
massive reorganization recodification
bill
uh that is being handled by Edna which
is
one as as is a result of the work that
we did over the summer which you know
two or three times a week we got
together with uh oplc staff and
shareholders and got their input some of
the stuff that you see in the uh
Governor's budget uh
I would be willing to say came out of
the discussions that we held although I
don't know
for sure
but those were certainly some of the
things that we discussed
I would remind people that the L and
oplc stands for licensure licensure by
definition means the ability to do
something that is otherwise illegal to
do
we've all received
um emails
regarding Landscaping
a literal interpret interpretation of
granting the license
to a person to plant the rose bush means
that you couldn't take care of your own
roses
or tulips or whatever but that's aside
from what this bill is it's just
a generalized discussion of it there's a
difference between certification which
is a qualification to do something and
licensure which is permission to do that
which is otherwise illegal to do
so uh just so the language is is
straight you'll notice this
commissioning was bipartisan this bill
is bipartisan uh happy to sponsor it
basically it sets up a non-lapsing fund
um
in general which passed the DNA
committee they've the Edna committee
requested that we put a cap on that
which is in Amendment uh uh zero three
three two H which you should have
received today single page handout
um
which is there I had the opportunity to
spend some time with Senator Lang
formerly of this committee and his bill
apparently he uh forgot to signed on to
my bill
any DNA are in his ways and means uh
committee uh sets up the same thing they
added an amendment on to their bill
which requires reporting by oplc I just
spoke and it seems as all that would be
an acceptable the two can be easily
merged together at some time whether the
commedia conference or uh we adapt his
language or he adapts our language or
something like that but it would seem to
me that it would be both meeting the
needs of the Edna committee which wanted
a cap on the amount of funds that would
be retained by oplc and a
a reporting of the expenditures of the
funds both to me sound like an excellent
idea uh particularly since there has
been some question regarding uh uh how
this operates uh one of the other bills
we talked about was uh just recently was
the uh
um public race
um public notice of meetings which uh
communication was an issue within oplc
which uh the the commissioner uh readily
uh agreed that it was an issue and some
of the uh boards were acting more
independently than they were working
within the overall structure but
basically what this bill does is one
small part of a larger part that's going
to mesh together and come up the idea is
to have it separate from the budget in
statutory law regarding how it operates
and give each one of the sections a good
looking over as we go through and then
mesh them all together mash them up and
come up with something
so with that Madam chair I would be
happy to answer limited questions but I
would prefer to defer the operation of
oplc and how this fund would operate to
the uh the staff
questions for the sponsor
oh representative alberger
thank you madam chair I actually have
two questions and they're not related so
if you want to separate them that's fine
um I'm confused about two things and
I'll just do one at a time
um
there is a lapse at the end of the
biennium
correct currently yes and
I'm confused as to
why
given that we set up a budget now for
the next two years why that same process
wouldn't be happening for the oplc so
there shouldn't be a lapse in funding
just as with any other department
other departments do have carryover
funding
uh oplc doesn't everything that they
have lapses at the end of two years
which then leaves them with a gap year
I'll let oplc discuss that in more
detail as to how it operates if you
don't mind representative
follow-up
um actually separate I'm also trying to
figure out what kind of capital
expenditures are involved
bunches
I would like to hear more about them and
I'm sure that the commissioner will be
happy to explain thank you thank you
representative
yes we just passed a revenue estimate
and did any of that Revenue estimate
include uh
monies into the general fund from oplc
uh and I'm sure it's minuscule but is
there any at all you know they uh during
this this summer we learned that it goes
for a two three million dollars it's you
know omniscal monies come back it
depends on how many licenses are issued
it's a very flu it's a very Flex term
how much money is around when it's
around at the end of the biennium
um it's kind of like uh we used to have
a uh uh a tax in in the state that was
based on a product on site
and
the stuff got moved the day that they
took inventory and then it got moved
back the day after they took inventory
uh and that's kind of uh what happens
with a lot of the funds that that lapse
other questions representative all me
uh thank you
um
this
how much
um
is the total
total amount of of
fees
what's What's the total intake of the of
the is is this supposed to be a
department it's an office right
the exact number are what the
commissioner discussed that with you
what I will say is that uh these very
according to
um
how many people are applying for license
how much money is expended in order to
for example we learned that uh one of
the smaller licensed agencies is
Midwifery
we used to get a report from Midwifery
remember it was real small but the
largest number of complaints comes from
that department
why
oh I could say something but I won't
I'll get in trouble but uh
it's
that's that's what happens uh they need
extra funds from there so it gets taken
from others so as to the equity
equitability of the application of
license fees to other individuals into
visuals within the uh Universe of oplc
um this is a a method of smoothing that
out and being able to maintain uh what
the lower numbers which
would include Landscape Architects for
example uh regarding complaints and
investigations and having to deal with
this that whatever that comes up with a
professional board
um
their costs are going to be lower
therefore their license is going to be
lower but they're actually paying more
now because they need to shift some of
the money from them and everyone else in
order to pay for activities regarding
this particular uh profession or that
particular profession wherever they have
it happens to be the target at the
current time so this is a buffer if you
will to allow uh being able to handle
those uh
transitory complaints
did I say that right did you have a
follow-up
uh that the boards have more duties more
benefits uh than just on listening to to
the complaints and dealing with them yes
we went into uh there's a lot of
information that the people in the
professions want to yes yes and the the
boards that were present in part in
partokan the discussion were largely in
favor of uh the the uh construct and and
supported the idea of keeping their
license fees uh for their entities
rather than shifting uh the cost to
cover some of the others as the uh as
the needs uh to investigate this that or
something else took place
um
the uh or initial uh
uh fiscal note regarding uh Florida here
down in finance just the other day on on
the 91 a issues the fiscal note got
wrong you notice that there's a
minuscule fiscal note attached to this
which
uh
it's you know doesn't say much of
anything
um but because there's not much of
anything to say uh this is a retained
fund and Reporting on it would make
sense and having a fixed amount than
anything in excess of that so that the
agency does not uh over indulge if you
will uh is uh
is is prevented
so representative Platt yes um
represent representative Oliver you said
that the Senate has passed a similar
version bill because I I think you said
that it came out of ways and means over
there anyway the other body
that's correct that came out of waste
means Tim Lang's committee
um Senator Lang's committee yeah
and uh it'll go to the Senate on
Thursday
all right so my quit the question I was
really asking is if they did pass it and
it's going to come over here we could
Amendment why do we need this bill
why could we just pull this bill and let
wait for the Senate version and amend it
for a couple of reasons one of which if
we put our position on regarding the cap
on the amount of monies within the bill
then we can put the two together but uh
and as I said earlier there is per there
are Provisions within Senator langsville
that were not included in this bill
although he's a close uh co-sponsor of
this bill that need to be merged
together but we need to get set our
position so that we can discuss it with
their position so we can come up with a
joint position so we can have a position
on the position
other questions from the committee
representative Phyllis
I have a lot of questions but the only
one I want to ask now is it has to do
with
the the timing
of this so
it says effective it it's an FN bill
which I thought meant we needed to have
taken care of it
quickly
but this is the second committee so we
gotta because it's FN it has to be taken
care of quickly
but the effective date is 60 days after
passage and I'm just confused of how
that
would even work because that doesn't
that gets into the following biennium
and just
now it creates the fun that's all it
does
and you're creating the fund the fund
will could be set up by uh dra
today it's the lapsing part that it
doesn't go to
yeah when would it lapse it would lapse
the next biennium
thank you
excellent question anything else from
the committee okay seeing none thank you
and don't forget your PIN card
okay well now welcome up Lindsay and I
cannot read your last name Lindsay I
apologize from the oplc
well that's my apology Madam chair I
have terrible handwriting
um thank you madam chair members of the
committee for the record my name is
Lindsay Courtney I am the executive
director of The Office of professional
lace Insurance certification and wish to
thank representative ulery for bringing
this bill forward we are fully in
support of this bill just to take a step
back oplc is
um completely agency funded we don't
receive any general funds we don't
receive any funds from any other source
other than licensing fees with the
exception of on occasion
um fees or fines administrative fines we
also receive
some funds from the Department of Health
and Human Services because we perform
certain tasks on their behalf as part of
compliance with CMS regulations but by
and large we are completely fully
self-funded agency
our budget is typically approximately
13.5 million dollars our Revenue varies
fairly substantially because our renewal
time periods are inconsistent we have
some months that are incredibly high in
terms of renewals and then some months
where we don't receive many renewals at
all most of our licensees renew within a
biennium although that up until recently
we did have several license types that
renewed every three years which created
a
you know varying
varying degrees of Revenue over the
course of several years
our fund is already a dedicated fund the
purpose of our fund is solely to provide
for the operational expenses of the
office which is really to give back to
the licensees and making sure that we're
administratively supporting the boards
within the office
right now however our fund's significant
portion of our funds lapse to the
general fund the change to the lapse uh
at the at the biennium card last year up
until that point our Labs had occurred
every fiscal year
and to give you an idea in 2016 we
lapsed 4.7 million 2017 5.5 2018 5.5
2019 we didn't lapse anything because
there was a change in the statute 2020
relapsed 6.9 2021 four million dollars
and last year we left 6 3.6 this is
problematic when you consider the fact
that our budget is only 13.5 million
dollars we are lapsing a large
significant portion of that into the
general fund so it's in essence our
licensee dollars are being utilized for
general fund purposes which obviously is
not the intent of our licensing fees
we believe it's important for us to
retain the licensee phase for two
purposes one that would allow us to
essentially reduce fees if appropriate
and two be able to save for Capital
expenditures those would typically
include software updates
um obviously that costs a significant
sum of money so we need to be able to
save for that and then two
we are looking into other alternatives
for physical location that is not least
space because presently we are paying a
significant sum toward our lease so
those are the two Capital expenditures
which I can think that we would say for
but it's very important that the office
be able to maintain some buffer because
we do see inconsistencies in our Revenue
that are at times driven by the market
for example real estate when Real Estate
is is really hot and the market is going
well we see an influx of applicants so
we see an influx in fees but we also see
an influx in the need for the support
that we provide we need to be able to
respond to that additionally unlike
other agencies on July 1 we start with
zero dollars we have no money
and July is not a renewal time frame so
it it's difficult for us obviously to
maintain our expenditures fortunately we
can make payroll even though we do not
have the money to cover that because of
the rsas surrounding that but it is
important for us and I think for the
agency operations to be able to have
some buffer some funds in the bank
and then lastly I would just say again
that the purpose of our funds is not to
fund anything other than the office and
so to the extent that we could reduce
those fees modify fees making sure that
we're not you know taxing people
inappropriately that is really the
intent behind this bill would that be
happy to answer any other questions
thank you representative Platt
thank you madam chair for letting me
take make the question thank you for
taking it Miss Courtney
if my mathematical mind says that this
is essentially a one-time loss of five
million bucks maybe to the estate in
front from there now it's the same
because we're just allowing you to keep
a buffer is that right
correct
representative rodford
thank you madam chair thank you director
Courtney I just want to and and just for
the record I I am licensed by oplc uh I
have a professional pharmacist license
and I I do want to hit on something that
representative ulery talked about but
it's because it's something I think that
that warrants discussion in that you've
got a number of boards that are charged
all kinds of fees
um and it sounds like some boards and
some professions utilize oplc perhaps
more than others yet
some professions like mine we pay a lot
of money for our licenses you know I
know like he mentioned Midwifery I think
they're 136 dollars for a license my
license is 278 dollars we charge two
thousand dollars for a non-resident
Pharmacy to just mail penicillin in in
into the state so I looking at this bill
I think it's a good time for us to
understand really how this would provide
more Equitable uh allocations of fees
and how we can reduce fees so have have
you do we have a plan or do you have a
plan that would would take us past this
bill into what what operationally we
would see to do that certainly and thank
you representative for the question this
bill doesn't directly address allocation
of indirect costs or costs back to the
boards allocation of Goss remains a a
huge problem
um and a challenge that we've been
working with the committee discusses at
least that was established by Senate
Bill 330. historically all of the boards
had statutory authority to establish
their own fees so most of the fees that
are established were established by the
boards via rulemaking or they were
established in statute which led to some
boards being essentially required to
charge you know 300 percent of their
expenses or not being able to meet their
expenses and cover their costs because
the statute provided a ceiling as to
what they could charge
so over the years oplc statute has been
amended to allow us to enact rules
regarding fees and I think the intent
was to allow us to basically Implement
an allocation method that was fair and
Equitable and ensured that all of the
boards were covering their costs but
they were not completely exceeding their
costs such that it became an
unconstitutional attacks
the problem with that legally was that
the board's authority to set fees and
the statutory fees were not removed from
the board statutes and so there was a
conflict a legal conflict and over the
last couple of years we had worked with
the legislature to remove portions of
fee setting Authority from the board
statutes we were not successful with the
exception of removing the statutory fees
but the committee or the commission
established by Senate Bill 330 has
recommended removing the board's ability
to promulgate rules regarding fees and
there is a bill a separate bill pending
that would basically perform that
cleanup
and so we are planning to move forward
with uh once we have the authority
establishing fees we do need to address
the cost allocation method and recently
we sat down with a bureau of accounts
to discuss what options were available
to us us from an administrative
standpoint to monitor to track what
staff are doing a large portion of our
costs are come from Personnel related
costs and so they presented some options
to us utilizing what the state already
has and we do plan to implement a new
cost allocation method starting with the
next fiscal year that'll require staff
who are providing support to more than
one board to track their time
accordingly so that then we can
determine which boards are utilizing
staff how often what that costs and then
we can allocate those costs directly to
the boards and reassess fees based on
those costs so we get a little bit more
of an accurate picture of what boards
are actually using
we
but until such time uh we you know we
need that data I don't think we'll see
all of the fees essentially be level set
it's going to take a couple of years to
get that access to that information
representative Olney
thank you on
representative abrami and I worked
maybe 10 years ago now on the first of
these mergers that finally created olpc
and then this committee got totally
removed from the process
to that
but we set the fees at that point after
a lot of work with all of the
stakeholders for the smaller Medical
health related including there were two
groups of midwives at that point and one
of them refused to talk to us
and their
there is the manufactured housing board
which is the odd person out
of the system and there is the
uh
dropped out of my mind right now there's
another one oh the the optician's
assistance
Group which I forget whether it's called
the board or not and I on those
really are incapable of paying for
themselves
are you eliminating I haven't been able
to find time to read hb2 yet to find out
what
besides the ones that have been
screaming at us are being eliminated I
do know that one of the reasons that
some of them are screaming is that it is
going to be much more difficult for
consumers to find what they need
and it's also means that oh people like
the cosmetologists aren't going to be
able to get the regular information
they've been getting about the poisons
and the chemicals they use
so
representative could you just clarify
your question I would like I would just
like to know what is going on
most of us for most of us we're only
hearing the people who are screaming but
we don't real are you going to eliminate
all the ones that can't pay for
themselves so that that wasn't the
objective or I don't believe that's the
objective of hb2
um
last year and I forget the bill
um the legislature did eliminate all
statutory fees and I think you're
referring to
um
Opticians midwives that had a statutory
fee of 110 dollars that statutory fee
was insufficient to cover their costs
and the commission that was established
by Senate Bill 330 discussed this at
length I raised the issue
in the context of lnas and I believe the
report
does document that that it was the
commission's belief and I share that
belief that professionals need to be
able to pay for their license and pay
for the costs that other professionals
should not be subsidizing the cost of
other professionals to the extent that
there is a question of whether or not
professions can't fully pay for the cost
of a license
maybe they need to be subsidized but it
shouldn't be by other people because
then that becomes an unconstitutional
tax so certainly you know the committee
could explore other mechanisms for
funding those professions
um but uh but I don't think it's
appropriate for example to shift costs
from pharmacies uh to other professions
that don't make a lot of money simply
because pharmacies have money because
that's not the purpose of a license fee
and so I think
um that is part of the discussion that
came out of this commission but I think
you're referring to hp2 which is
completely separate and distinct from
this bill and there are a couple of
professions that are proposed to be
eliminated in House Bill 2 you raise
cosmetology it's just the booths that
are a duplicative license there are a
couple of others but it's it's unrelated
to the issues of of peace
so
is is it
it I hope still a very good website
which is helps those places is that a
question on House Bill 2 because we
really should be focused on this I
really feel like we have a piece of the
tail of the elephant and that this has
been spread all over the place
and that most of us are out of the
conversation thank you
other questions for yes representative
elberger thank you madam chair can we
get a budget from the office I would
really like to get a breakdown of costs
and revenues before I think about voting
on this yeah that's right I can
certainly provide that'd be great thank
you
other comments yes representative
fellows or questions here we're in a
public hearing questions so I'm going to
ask a question but it's it's I'm just
going to ask for a confirmation and that
doesn't count as my real next question
so
so when I go to the to um lba's website
and I can find on there the oplc
presentation to finance and I believe in
there isn't there a little chart that
lists the all of the ones that are
proposed for elimination
yes because we anticipated that the
division one Finance may ask what the
fiscal impact would be for eliminating a
licenses so to be a little bit proactive
we did the math and and if hb2 were to
go through we would lose about uh that
was the reason I asked that question is
because that's a reference to answer a
lot of these questions that are coming
up okay thank you Representatives so so
now for my real question
so
I I I I'm very concerned that the
philosophy that apparently came out of
this study which I have not read
is that a a group of people who are
licensed for a particular license are s
are somehow
always responsible for paying the whole
cost of that license because in my mind
the purpose for licensing anybody is to
protect the public
so I can understand that maybe
there's some issue with
charging them more than somehow their
allocation is but for some not to be
able to support what is a reasonable
license fee is not a reason to put them
on the cut list do you agree
um well I agree that that's not a reason
to put them on the cut list except that
I would disagree with the premise that
that is the basis for the proposed
repeals in hb2
um that I mean again that's not an oplc
requested bill but if you look at the
proposed professions to be eliminated in
House Bill 2 those are not professions
that have difficulty with paying for
their license fees I think and I can't I
don't I'm not taking a policy position
on this but I think the legislature has
a question that needs to be answered
which is if the purpose of licensure
which it is is to protect the public
then why are the professionals who are
required to obtain a license forced to
fund the cost of that license you know
some have argued that it should be
General funded not taking a position but
if you are going to require their
licensed professionals to fully pay for
the cost of having the license how is it
fair to make other professionals pay for
somebody else's license as opposed to
the public as a whole and I think that's
what we're talking about because for
example you have
cosmetology Cosmic the cosmetology board
which has much more expenses than most
other boards because they conduct
inspections they're paying for about 46
percent of their costs what that means
is acupuncturists accountants other
licensed professionals are paying for
cosmetologists now if you want other
people to pay for cosmetologists why
should it be limited to those who are
required to have a license should it not
should the funds not come from another
source so I think that's the policy
question that the legislature has to
Grapple with but if the if the
determination is that licensees have to
fully pay for the cost of their license
which is what is current currently
statutorily required then I don't think
it is appropriate to have other
individuals subsidize that license and
it actually is a tax
thank you follow up to that look I need
to bring this in a little bit and remind
folks that this is directly okay let me
just remind everyone right now we we've
gone back and forth this is why it's a
little confusing we've been doing uh
full committee work sessions which is
appropriate to do more of this
conversational stuff however this is an
actual public hearing and we are here to
listen to testimony and ask clarifying
questions not to debate or you know
showcase our profession our opinions on
things I just want to remind everyone
that this is a public hearing and we
really do need to be focused on the
revenue aspects of this bill and we can
talk about hb2 separately later okay
okay go ahead yeah so this has to do
with transfer to the general fund do
things that happen related to licensures
ever impact agencies that are other
agencies like the AG when somebody
um actually for example that that
medical technician that gave a lot of
people hep C
so what
um what situations
um that happen can be impacted outside
your agency that that could justify
sending some of that money back to the
general fund so is your question whether
licensed professionals have an impact on
other state agencies or whether the our
agency has an impact on other state
agencies
I'd say both with respect to our agency
we fully pay for the cost of the
services provided by other agencies we
fully fund two and a half positions at
the Department of Justice we also pay
for indirect costs through doit and we
have direct costs through doit we also
have an agreement with division of
personnel we pay them fifty thousand
dollars a year to provide backup
services for the HRC so we are fully
funded with certainly licensed
professionals can impact the state but I
would argue that's not a licensing issue
that is an issue of you know criminal
nature or other types of conduct that
don't fall within the license licensing
jurisdiction
follow up yeah can you just explain the
AG positions that related to are they
advisory or uh
so there is there could be some
impact outside your agency other than
paying I.T and personnel which all
agencies do
so there could be some
so your positions
I I disagree with that I think that the
agency fully pays for the cost of all
services
um for the state we we pay more than our
fair share
um you know for example we are fully
funding two and a half positions at doj
to provide one legal counseling to the
agency and two to prosecute cases of
unlicensed practice and a paralegal now
I can tell you that those people
likely do work on other things unrelated
to oplc but we still pay for the full
full cost of those positions
so you know I do
we are fully funding and fully paying
for our costs and then some
representative Platt yes thank you madam
chair thank you for taking my question
does not directly apropos of this bill
because this bill is just
saying uh non-lapse versus lapse you
want it to non-lapse but you brought it
up earlier question uh about uh loss of
Revenue coming from loss of reduction in
number of licenses required
and have you also done an analysis to
see how you could cut your cost so you
could stay uh it's this is a net loss or
gain out of that and if there's a net
loss you would you have to make that up
by increasing license to all the
remaining licenses
I I think yes we have done an analysis
although I think it's slightly premature
because hb2 not only proposes to
eliminate certain license types but it
also proposes to transfer certain
license types to oplc
so it's unclear what impact that will
have to a revenue from a revenue
standpoint we I did provide finance
division one without analysis of what we
would see in terms of reduction in
Revenue but I'll say for example just by
eliminating lnas that's 10 of our
licensed population that would clearly
result in a reduction of the necessary
administ administrative support so I
think we would see and observe and
certainly have to a reduction in overall
cost to supporting the boards that said
you know if we were to get the boxing
Commission in auctioneers and others
that are proposed to transfer over we
need to do that analysis as to the
impact of the revenue and administrative
support and our experience has been that
when we take on a board typically
there's a little bit more work involved
on the front to basically try to
synergize that board statutes with ours
kind of clean it up to make sure that it
works with the agency but I I do
anticipate that if the license types
were eliminated we would see a reduction
in overall necessary expenditures
any other questions from the
members no okay great thank you so much
thank you for your time and um I will
recognize representative ulery again
um who might have forgotten to mention
something
thank you madam chair uh I was actually
uh stimulated uh to by the by the
question that was asked by
representative almi yes you are getting
the elephant's tail but there's a reason
for that because some of the changes
need to take place
of themselves not for any other reason
and they need to take place whether or
not hb2 or any other bill passes for
example uh last Friday open division one
or over in division one uh we discussed
public records public access public
meeting notices that needs to take place
within oplc to make sure that the
agencies know that they've got to follow
91a
simple as that that stands alone this
particular bill will stand alone as well
as the Senate version that's why it came
from either side
because it needs to take place in order
to assure the funding and they can do
the other activities that they're doing
right now so in one sense of the of the
fact yeah you're getting bits and pieces
but that was done deliberately by the
commission so we could fully examine
each of the ones that's going to stand
alone now the entire thing is a separate
bill and then we'll put everything
together and those of you who have been
around for more than a couple of years
understand that that meshing process
that takes place is is an interesting
animal in and of itself I wouldn't say
it's an elephant it could be a donkey it
depends but
thank you madam chair
are you open to taking questions
have you ever known me not to want to
talk okay represent only
he reminded me about the question I did
want to ask the director which is about
how they came to the five thousand five
million dollars
that was a recommendation out of the
Edna committee at the time this bill was
presented dedna as the first committee
uh they wanted to put a cap on it and
the it was agreed uh that somewhere
between three and five so I took the
high you know it's it's a number
director Courtney would you care to
weigh in while we're thank you thank you
thank you um representative earlery is
correct originally this bill did not
contain the five million dollar ceiling
um I I completely support a ceiling
because I think that's necessary in
order to avoid
um costs you know continue to drive up
um five million dollars is typically a
little
um more than what we lapse at the end of
every fiscal year so three to five
million it seemed like a reasonable
buffer for us to allow us to save for
Capital expenditures for example our
most recent contract which was fully
arpa funded so not funded by the state
but the state's most recent contract was
about 3.5 million dollars for software
so you know it's anticipated that that
would be a reasonable cost that we would
see for future Capital expenditures
representative Phyllis um yeah so I in
terms of capital expenditures so I'm
thinking my understanding is that admin
Services owns buildings so if you wanted
or long-term leases so if you wanted to
move to a different building that that
would have to go through the you know
capital budget appropriation and
the other thing you said
um I'm gonna forget in terms of lapsing
um you're trying you're lapsing the in
like the entire operation oh the I know
the um the I thought the an upgrade in
the computer system is all already in
the governor's budget
not correct or
um I'm not I'm not aware of a computer
upgrade for or PLC it could be that
there's an upgrade a system-wide upgrade
but
um our licensing portal is the upgrade
that I was talking about
um it is currently an Enterprise
solution but oplc utilizes at least 90
percent of it
um and it is uh right now the fact that
we don't have a functioning licensing
portal has required us to utilize
additional Personnel I think with the
state and you'll and I think
you've probably observed this what the
state is is facing is a Workforce
Challenge and so there's a need to
really leverage technology and move away
from from using manual processes and
people to technology and we're kind of
in that middle transition
representative liebly
thank you informational question
um the presentation that oplc did to did
for finance is that something we can
find on your website just a
informational question I can certainly
send it to you I do believe it's on the
Gen Court website as well
it's in it's in it's in the LBA website
representative Ames could you give us
what that word is
a uh
menus is LBA and you would then click on
the budget documents and budget 24 to
25.
and then go through a list and you get
to this document we're talking about
yes thank you finance division one is
another uh Pathways that you have to go
down thank you okay thank you I don't
have any more oh go ahead representative
we did all that research thank you what
was the name she should be looking for
of that study
oplc what
okay I don't have any more pink cars
anyone else here who would like to speak
oops she's gone away
okay all right with that then we will
now close the public hearing on House
Bill 445. thank you
okay guys so now we've got 10 minutes
before our first work session
and
I know there's a lot of questions about
hb2 we have to try to stay focused on
this bill
which I believe simply changes it from a
lapsing fund to non-lapsing and putting
a cap on it so let's try to focus on
that and um we have tentatively
scheduled an executive session on this
next week so make sure you ask Jordan
ulery any questions you have he is the
our resident expert and he can help us
with this and then we also now have
um director Courtney here
um
uh would you mind sharing your email
address that way if folks have questions
they could reach out to you
perfect
that would be great because you could
hear there's a little bit angst here and
we uh the commission report is there a
commission report uh representative
ulery that you could share with us as
well
thank you director that would be
fabulous great because we're interested
in this topic and we're learning great
all right so we'll take a little break a
little stretch break come back 11.
thanks guys
we are not hearing public input unless
we happen to see a technical expert here
that might be able to answer a technical
question but otherwise in general we're
not here to listen to anyone else from
the outside we are here to work together
as a team and seeing if we can get some
sort of better information on this bill
and maybe see if there's a direction we
want to go so this uh bill was uh this
is House Bill 450 and the prime sponsor
is our own representative Schoenberg who
um has done a lot of work on this so you
know if you could maybe kind of get us
remind us about the bill let us know
your thoughts and then kind of take it
from there
excellent
sounds fine Madam chair uh
first of all just a quick history
historical lesson I brought this up back
when House Bill 435 was presented to the
house last year
and I took it on as
it seemed like big Corporation was
getting
more of the breaks than the business the
small business World
um
I was trying to make it on Level Playing
Field
and uh in the research that I did I came
across
the 2014 commission that did a study
on uh
let me call it
title was
just taxes
uh and they're con their conclusion at
the end was that tax Simplicity is a
good tax policy
and a competitive goal should be
implemented where possible and
I made my presentation of the house and
it wasn't passed they went another
Direction which was the 80 percent
of the uh
nol
so this year I brought it back with Mr
Jim uh use am I going to say this right
seglio who couldn't make it today he had
a conflict he was the gentleman that
presented last time
and uh
after my presentation and his
presentation he met with the dra
and
presented
what you have in front of you now a
Amendment
to house bill 450.
he did not know which direction the
committee was going to go on this
because he is of the opinion that it
should be a 100 percent
for the small businesses also
well I don't think that's going to
happen now as uh the lobbyist Mr Bragdon
made a presentation and said
when they originally passed the 80
percent was to take away the Dual
appropriation not Appropriations
apportionment factors
so Mr ociglio had couldn't make it today
but he did send to me a first he said I
think he sent to all of you this
net operating loss Provisions by the tax
Foundation I think it's in a black and
white cover you have there
and there was some good reading in there
but he also sent to me and he he says
if we do nothing
here's a let me read this to you he says
I would want to emphasize that our nol
Provisions as previously noted and
discussed are lacking compared to other
states and that is addressed in this tax
Foundation note
especially on page four
and uh
are hiking compared to other States
including our neighbors this doesn't go
unnoticed and he's trying to say this
that there are businesses that are
looking at various States so we do
nothing or we address this
problem that he feels is there by going
to the 80 percent increase our 10-year
carry forward period
to 20 years
or conform to the federal provisions
which is indefinite and that's on page
five I believe it shows you what the nol
provisions are for the other states
uh
or we remove the 10 million dollar cap
and keep the 80 percent
with the 10-year limit
or
remove the eighty percent taxable income
limitation that was his suggestions uh
the
states of New England Maine is on the
Federal
IRC which is unlimited about years 100
percent uh no 80 I think it is no
80 percent
uh
Vermont on page five you will see that
it it has the 10 years but it does not
have uh any limit on the carry forward
the amount uh
Massachusetts is the 20 years
but no limit on the amount of carry
forward
Connecticut is 20 years no amount
carried forward
no restriction and Rhode Island's only
five years
so that is where we're at he felt that
we should do something as a committee
to maybe change one of our approaches
and they were once again
increase our 10-year carry forward
period to 20 years
or remove the 10 million dollar limit
or remove the 80 percent
and I would be happy with any
suggestions any way that this committee
would like to go with this we do have
this amendment that if we do nothing at
least we change the applicability date
from July 1st 19 uh
what do they do with it
yeah I have the same problem at home I
dropped papers and I uh
I'm line eight I believe it says uh
limited and adjusted is one of the
the changes and then the line 13
the effective date shall take effect
December 31st 2023 instead of July 1st
of this year
so that that's where we're at
your opinions are valued on this may I
just ask a quick so this is changing
from your original Bill does it also
remove the 10-year Max oh it does not it
changes nothing else except those two
dates those two lines
limited and adjusted and the effective
date
okay
so much representative Almy
just about in fact I think all the other
states
we depend hugely on the business taxes
as part of our revenues
on for them it's 10 20 15 of their
revenues at the most for us it's around
35 now it used to be 40.
uh
and
we don't have a fiscal note for anything
except what's in this bill at this point
I have no idea how much it would cost us
to go unlimited
or to
um
to make it
to not limit on
the amount
that can be carried forward
and I've never heard such a note being
created since the time when we had some
capacity to tackle this problem
we do have our friends from the dra here
no could we ask you to this would be a
technical in input that we need from you
um on House Bill 450
obviously you guys did a fiscal note on
the original bill
but we're talking about a couple of
different scenarios and wondered if you
could weigh in on the fiscal impact if
you can so
the current bill
removes the 80 percent limitation
other Concepts that I think were brought
forward was to remove
the number of year
the number of year cap
and then there's a to remove the dollar
cap so on those two things
is there any way that you could do a
fiscal note
or advise us
foreign
tax policy Council from a dra and uh
Lauren O'Sullivan senior financial
analyst with the dra
so I'm just thinking about the um
the scenario when if we're removing the
um the 10-year limitation
for the carryovers
that's one scenario and then the other
scenario is removing the 10 million
dollar cap
um and then
how would we calculate the fiscal note
impact
um
does it involve a dartboard
I think we have to think about it
further to see if we can actually
produce a fiscal note
a fiscal impact on that or not because
what we have is information from the
past so that's how we've been doing our
fiscal knows it's been a static analysis
of these situations in the past and
we've always had that income limitation
sorry the um the cap of the 10 million
limitation or one one form or the other
in older years it was not 10 million
dollars it was another another amount
and then we've always had that um that
10-year
limitation as well in terms of the
carryovers from the year the loss was
generated
so in terms of
um
whether if we can
perform a calculation without those
limitations I'm not sure we'll just have
to look at the data once again
um but bear in mind uh i s just just
speaking anecdotally if um 10 years
limitation
potentially just thinking potentially
the the nols could have been awfully
claimed within that 10 years I'm not
sure
um but that could be that potential
um and therefore there would be no you
know okay over the past 10 years could
be
um
and then with the 10 million dollar uh
limitation that is on a year by year
basis every year where there's an animal
that's loss is generated that 10 million
dollars is applied to that particular
year for carryover to next year and if
next year this organization has another
nol year again and then there's a that
10 that 10 million dollars
could be a new 10 million dollar limit
on on that particular year as well so
every year that's going to be that 10
million dollar limitation as opposed to
a a 10 million dollar limitation
throughout the entire situation
um
so I guess
just
so summarize I think we we just have to
look at what we have and see how look at
it carefully see if we can really
generate some kind of calculation
representative Army
thank you uh could you approach this a
different way and find out from
Massachusetts and
and anyplace else that seems relevant on
if they could tell you about what
percentage of uh the losses that they
take on these are after those
limitations
after after the 10 million or after the
10-year I know that those two cross-sect
each other which makes it different
difficult right but
um
we could try that but however just bear
in mind that uh
Massachusetts have their own tax laws
and and they calculate differently
um so
whatever result from their nol could be
potentially very vastly different from
our
what we get from for our nols
yeah
it it
does seem to me if I could
say something about that that
in the past I've always thought okay if
you can't stay if you're still losing a
profit in at the 10th year you must
be dying or you have a major sugar daddy
but with the merging of businesses and
the Takeover of businesses in order to
have a loss later in one place to offset
another I don't think that works these
days
the nol is still
um according to our New Hampshire
statutes the nol is oh it's still
um applicable to that particular entity
so it's it is um you calculate the
annual for that particular entity and
you aggregate out to calculate your when
you file combined return
um so that that that tax
um
that the nol element remains with that
particular entity even though if it gets
bought up so it's still that particular
entity yeah
so that a company could come along and
just buy up a couple of our failed
businesses and absorb their nols
as long as as long as the entity that's
being bought up Still Remains
semi-functional yeah so the animal
remains with that particular entity it
won't move out of that entity
representative Phyllis did I see your
hand up
um yes but this is the kind of question
I was
thinking about and
that
the only other thing I can think of to
to ask related to this is can you tell
us if there were or how many companies
currently are are taking their nol out
out for 10 years
or or some amount of time
um
I'm just thinking how our system works
and I I don't think we have that
information because once our system
limits the um the schedule to 10 years
and then once that
very first nol year
passes that 10 years it gets dropped off
so um it's
it doesn't we don't capture that
information
um
as a carryover next year and a year
after that
follow-up yeah if you didn't go out to
could you look at nine years and would
you know that who's carried it out for
nine years right yep so so look up to
the to the 10th year and see the very
first year if there's still any nols
available to be carried over
I guess that would answer your question
do you have any sense of what that would
be or you'd have to go and look I I we
would have to go back in and look at
that yes
other hands representative putt yes this
is directed to representative Schomburg
thank you representative Schomburg the
80 percent of yeah right here 80 I'm a
little reluctant to do away with because
to me it's a revenue smoothing mechanism
uh when you hit a real deep recession
like 2008 it protects the state from too
much of a downturn and it's no real even
though it's it's a timing issue because
then the business can carry the rest of
it Forward would you be amenable too
what you said you were amenable to
something like uh a 20-year limitation
and 20 million dollars and keep the 80
percent
huh
I would go along with what the committee
would do I think when it came over from
the other body
to this committee last year and it was a
19 or 20 to 1 vote
to move forward with it I don't think
they understood all the implications
that went with it as uh the obvious Mr
Brighton pointed out at that time that
they weren't thinking so much of
they were looking at the chapter C
companies at that time trying to help
them out and I I sometimes raises the
hair on the back of my neck when I hear
just one side being presented so uh I
have no problem with an amenable
approach to this I don't know what my uh
leader might say
uh I'd like to hear her opinion on that
but just in listening to what your
initial presentation today was you also
talked about simplification so I don't
know how we incorporate that
representative almond did you have
anything on that
yeah I'm opposed to the other ones the
the reason that I can
grudgingly support taking five to six
million a year out of our revenues is
that
it looks like the people that are
are suffering most from this would be
the businesses that just got started and
that are operating on a shoestruct
shoestring for the first few years and
the recession comes along they get a
loss and the loss
only they can only take 80 percent of
that loss the
and until they finish that loss off and
maybe
um
they're operating on too little money to
continue that first and second year
while they're trying to get all of their
their loss back from before
and drop out of the market and
and so we're discouraging
startups with that started with maybe a
really good idea but insufficient
capital
you do know that FedEx started that way
too and they lost first five years of
their operation they lost money
and uh
in a few years in between him
I don't know if there's any way to get
some kind of statistics on
on the businesses aggregated statistics
on the businesses that that
um
got that had losses
on
that they're going to have to be taking
over multiple years
um the the statistics that I brought
today is a compilation of the
information that we have from our tax
expenditure report
and it details out
um the
amount of the number of business
organizations that used an animal
deduction for any particular fiscal year
and a total the total nol used in that
particular fiscal year and the total tax
decrease due to the nol
um for fiscal year 22 there was about uh
6995 business organizations that used to
I know nol deduction
uh the total animal used was 470
approximately 470 million and a total
tax decrease due to nol was at 36
approximately 36.2 million
um
and the year before that facilia 21 the
total tax decrease due to annual was at
28 million
and before that was 27.8 Million so it's
around it's around a year
the 30 million Mark for uh
tax decrease due to nol and the the
number of business organizations that
had been claiming the nol deductions
year over year has been around
averaging about maybe
um
six thousand seven hundred business
organizations
representative only could we
could you apply the inverted triangle to
that
so that we knew which ones were pretty
large businesses that can probably
handle this and
uh but not who they are yes we could try
but uh
this you know
making sure not to cross the line of
disclosure
representative oh sorry
a thousand dollars
representative horse thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question so if we were to look back
after say 2010 to 2017
the statistics you gave just a little
while ago does that hold true from like
10 to 17 after the recession the big
recession before the covid
uh the information I have is all the way
back to fiscal year 20 of 2015.
excellent okay um so for 2015
it's about the same so the business
organizations that use the NL deductions
was about 5 000 business organizations
and the total tax decrease due to nol uh
was 21 million
and then in 2016 fiscally 2016 went up
to 34 million of total tax decrease and
it went back down to 25 million 23
million so it's about it's around that
neighborhood of of numbers okay very
good so it's probably in that 25 to 30
range somewhere right thank you very
much welcome
representative liebly
to wrap my mind around this so prior to
um the nol
that businesses could take was 100 not
80 right
yes sorry so those numbers that you gave
us prior to 2018
that was a higher
businesses could take 100 it's not 2018.
it is
text year
um
text texture 22 oh it takes you 21.
um because I'm sorry for
tax year 22 is when we uh
when we conform to the tcga the the IRC
of 2018 ah okay
so um and that's when we have the 80
percent uh cap okay prior to that so
prior to tax year 22
um we were not we were using the the the
nol deduction claim was using the IRC of
2016. it was some some old old year it
wasn't it wasn't conformant it wasn't
the same Conformity as the rest of the
BPT statutes for in terms of IRC has it
had its own um
Conformity year okay so let me restate
my question and make sure I have it
right so prior to 2022 the numbers that
you're referring to the nol that
businesses could write off was 100 not
80. that's great okay so we have very
little
information actually that where
businesses will only be able to write
off 80. it'll be this this year this
year yes okay so the numbers that you're
giving us
are with an nol of 100 really
that is correct okay so moving to the 80
will be new for businesses in New
Hampshire and for Revenue
uh that is correct yes um yep okay so
one more kind of how this works question
and then kind of a policy question so
the nol
um the 10-year limit and the 10 million
dollar limit
um
so if I lose money
in 2000
I it let's say I lose a lot of money in
um and I am able to write that off over
10 years because you know I made enough
money to offset my losses and I get to
write that off for 10 years
um would that mean that I could write
off
10 million dollars
each of those years or in total
the 10 million dollar limit is from the
so the year where I incur the last the
year that you include a loss whatever
the loss is and then you carry it over
because in the year of the loss you're
not
using the laws you're carrying it over
to the next year to use the laws so when
you carry over that the amount that you
can carry over is limited to 10 million
dollars okay and then I can write that
off over 10 years or over one year kind
of just depending right depending money
I make yes okay
now if I lose
10 million dollars again later
I can write it off again later
that is correct okay thank you for that
so as I'm thinking through this if if
the idea here is to help level the
playing field
um and I guess I'm thinking about that
in two ways one way to support small
businesses
um which who I'm assuming would not lose
10 million dollars in one year if it's a
small business
um
and to support new businesses because
often businesses lose money when they're
new to to try and get going
I'm I'm looking at the three variables
that we might want to play with to
support new businesses and small
businesses and it seems to me that going
from 10 to 20 years or 10 million
dollars to 20 million dollars would tend
to benefit larger corporations who are
playing in that field
whereas going from 80 percent to a
hundred percent of nol could really
benefit very small businesses because
for a small business losing twenty
thousand dollars and only being able to
write off 80 percent of that could be a
much bigger pain point
so it seems to me like if we really want
this to benefit
small businesses or upstart businesses
who down the road might be able to pay
bet or BPT to the state it seems like
the
the variable we wanna
look at is that 80 so if small
businesses cannot can write off a
hundred percent of their loss it may be
a very small amount in Revenue to the
state right it might be twenty thousand
dollars
um as opposed to twenty million dollars
and it seems like that would really help
small businesses survive and be
competitive
um and make it to the point where
they're contributing to the state's
revenues so
um I would be
grateful if anyone can kind of address
that point and present a different
perspective so that I know if I'm
getting that right but that's kind of
my understanding at this point and I
would be grateful for people to help me
understand that better thank you
weigh in on that
it representative plan
representative I think you're right on
the money
with respect to who it impacts my
concern with the eighty percent wasn't
that it was simply Revenue stabilization
for the state because we could have a
real bad year I and it may be the cons
my concern is overblown because it is
small businesses mostly the uh that that
would take advantage of this and that
the amount of money isn't that it isn't
it most of the money comes from the huge
corporation so maybe my concern is
overblown that's a concern I thought
your analysis was correct
representative Rochford
thank you uh I I I think representative
Leafly brings up a an excellent point
and um and and I think that I I think
it's important we don't get stuck on a
10 million dollars uh you know in in
speaking to that what you're talking
about
um of course eliminating the 80 to 100
for for small businesses is excellent
something that I can relate to as a
small business owner but looking down
the road as far as attracting businesses
into the state you know we've got
Cambridge Massachusetts which is a
biotech capital of the east coast and
wouldn't we like to get a little bit of
that
um and these are you know these are
startup companies and you know they
could conceivably be
small businesses other than the fact
that they deal with large amounts of
money but those large amounts of money
are can be gone whether the FDA says yes
or no to a New Drug and you know I think
so so you know to us here 10 million
dollars is a very large amount of money
but if we're in the business of
attracting businesses and attracting
people who could be the next Amgen or
ABV or or whatever I think that you know
eliminating that cap or raising the cap
to much higher is much more in line with
looking down the road to Growing our bet
and BPT
um and and I think by going limiting the
80 to 100 percent does what we needed to
do for small businesses but maybe being
a little more
aggressive with the second part of that
could Foster the growth of new
Industries in the State uh with with
that
representative Ames
thanks
um
yeah I
I think the 80 percent has been
um
well supported
um I mean eliminating it
um
so that's good and we've got a fiscal
analysis on that and uh a fiscal note
and uh
um it costs some money apparently about
six million dollars a year was the note
in that range and um
so that's good I
beyond that we don't have
analysis in terms of impact and I
wouldn't be comfortable
making a big change like that without
some attempt at getting solid data to
the extent to which we can get it
I think that at the hearing on this bill
dra uh suggested that an amendment this
is my note I don't remember the details
needed is needed to apply this to all
types of businesses does that ring a
bell with you yes yes that's correct
what do we need are the amendment has
been suggested by uh representative
Schoenberg in the uh the
the the one that was uh that
representative Sean book just handed out
oh that's on there okay so we've got the
yes um I I do want to just add one more
uh representative Schoenberg
to uh the effective date the one on line
13.
if we can just tweak it a bit more just
slightly
um to this act shall take effect for
taxable periods ending on or after and
then the date
yeah so just to add there between effect
and December so for taxable peers ending
on or after yeah
okay
um
so I guess I guess that's yeah I think I
I I I from my perspective only for what
it's worth it's so a good bill and uh
we've got some uh minor technical
changes to it but basically it's the
bill that was presented
um and uh
I'm comfortable with going forward on it
but not as I say even though some good
concerns have been expressed uh the
other Lids on this bill right now
representative Phyllis
yeah I'm still trying to get my head
around like exactly who's using this and
how it's being used and I think in terms
of the small businesses you know that
this is just like the you know Mom and
Pop or you know just a one or two
employees I'm I'm wondering if they
frequently take a net operating loss
um every year and the reason that they
might be able to do that is because
they can set their salary at anything
that's reasonable and their salary can
control you know what their profit is
but they still get by there's still a
little business and they get by
I don't know does that make sense to you
understand yeah yeah so that I'm
wondering what part of the population is
that in which case it doesn't really
matter if it's like 80 or 100 it's just
you know I mean you can pay yourself
eighty thousand dollars a year or you
can pay yourself a hundred and twenty
thousand dollars a year no one's going
to question that you you know just avoid
paying the tax altogether and for the
larger
businesses the ones that move into the
state big ones big losses if they lose
three years in a row lose money three
years in a row doesn't matter if it's
like 80 percent or a hundred percent
they're not using it at all because
they're still those first years they
just are not paying any taxes because
they didn't make any profit
right
so
I'm not sure it matters
bullying I don't I don't I don't really
see a big benefit to anybody for for
changing it but on the other hand I
don't think it's a disaster if we
change the uh
the the limit you know
the maximum
I I prefer not to see the 10 years
change though that just seems
Kim did you want to comment on that yeah
I just wanted to make aware that that 80
cap
um it caps the the amount of nol that
can be claimed up to the 80 of the
federal taxable income for that
particular year
and then
the excess of that carries over to the
next year so it's not like 80 and that's
it you're not gonna get the rest of the
the nol
it gets carried over to the next year so
it's it sort of prolongs the uh the nol
claim versus claiming it all in one one
year
um so just
yeah
misunderstand so a company that loses
for three years in a row forget forget
about the carry board they just lose
money three years in a row
they don't pay any taxes
on no business profits tax those three
years
and there's no point in even using the
carry forward they don't they don't use
to carry forward at all so
yes but then the the amount would still
be carried over to the year when they
would use it
right
yes
representative Olney
thank you we've got a lot of startups in
my community and I'm thinking also if
the dean Cayman people on
they attract
Young
scientists uh
that are working for a lot less than
they could have made if they went into
an old business
but on if they can't earn enough
in the year that they can pay the rent
in places like Lebanon and Manchester
and and such on
then the business has problems so there
there it you can't just reduce
especially in New Hampshire you can't
reduce your cost of living enough to fit
under the circumstance that you're
talking about in a lot a lot of places
can I just it sounds like we have a lot
of uncertainty here that's what I'm
hearing and uh I think we this is a very
important topic that we all care a lot
about representative Schamberg would
this be something you'd consider
retaining I don't know does it need more
time do we because we're going to start
running out of time soon I'm just
throwing that out there because it just
I'm hearing a lot of different things
and please tell me your thoughts
I think there are a lot of good points
have been brought up
by representatively and representative
rofford
uh and representative Ames
maybe a longer look at it would would
help us understand it better and give
more time for the dra to come up with
more uh data
and somehow be creative and how they get
it to show to us how it works
so I have no objection to a retainment I
don't know if anybody else does
I you know this is just discussion
obviously you'll go back to your
caucuses go back home tonight look over
your notes think about what you want to
do tomorrow but I just you know it just
it's a great Bill we obviously spending
a lot of time on because if you think
it's a great bill but we just it seems
like there's a lot of questions still
out there representative Almy
yes I do think
on if we send this bill out now the
finance committee isn't going to react
positively to its existence
taking out a 12 million more out of out
of the stuff that they have to cut on
and the
the Senate I don't know where they would
be on that but if we wait until the fall
perhaps things will look better
wouldn't that be nice and maybe less
uncertainty is I think the the biggest
challenge we face right now in this
committee um yes other comments while
we're discussing
okay uh any more questions while we have
expert guidance here yes representative
Ames
the data that you were looking at
um did you say that was from a tax
expenditure report
that's correct uh the Texas we publish a
tax expenditure report annually and it's
available on our website one of the
items on the tax expenditure report is
the nol expenditure yeah glad to hear
that it's being used yes
okay any other comments before we wrap
it up okay let's uh wrap it up now and
then uh take a lunch break until one
o'clock and then we'll continue with
some more work sessions
thank you very much for that discussion
and thank you for being here
tomorrow
then next week so on Monday
March 13th we have two second committee
bills one house bill 639 which is the
cannabis bill
we're going to do that at 9 00 a.m and
we're going to do it in this room
the chairman of the former committee did
not believe we need to go to reps Hall
we shall see
we shall see about that
but we've got the whole morning planned
for that and we will be focusing on the
revenue aspects and trying not to go
backwards on the policy itself
then in the afternoon of next Monday
we have house bill 494.
also a second committee bill which has
to do with the fertilizers I have not
read that yet
so that's what that is and then I was
going to plan a day for next Tuesday but
it is a town meeting day
so that would put a lot of people in a
tough spot so what we did is scheduled
an exec session next Wednesday and it
should have been listed for all
remaining bills so anything we don't get
done tomorrow we'll try to get done then
and if we can deal with these two second
committee bills then we will if we can't
we have more time on those
now the house clerk told us this morning
uh let me look at my deadlines
that we must
have everything to our committee Clerk
no to the house clerk by noon on March
16th which is next Thursday
so keep in mind we have to go backwards
a little bit
as soon as we can get things done at an
executive session we should have blurbs
committee reports
written up and ready to go so the sooner
we can feed all that stuff to our
committee assistant the sooner she can
feed it to the clerk so that then we
know for scheduling purposes how how
sessions are going to go but we're now
next week is going to start to be more
deadline oriented but we're going to try
to get done as much as we can this week
does that make sense
do we have copies yet
Karen's working on those okay
sorry everyone we're just waiting for
copies and it's a busy day here I guess
so we'll get there soon
there was a
physical like it's a full copy of the
bill was requested that included some
sort of fiscal note was that was
requested and then there's some sort of
a summary of the different parts of the
bill and it was sent out but I don't
know if everyone has it so just making
sure
sorry about that guys all right so
uh this is now a committee work session
on
House Bill 607
so reminder This Is Us speaking amongst
ourselves to learn more about this bill
um and this is not a time for public
testimony however we have experts in the
room who are available to answer
questions as they come up so this is
your bill representative just said do
you want to start us off sure and and I
guess
and forgive me for the uh copies stuff
uh if Karen's kind of busy I'm sure
everybody noticed the level of
uh action over here in the lob today so
she couldn't get it done for us rapidly
nonetheless
um
there's a lot of uh members on the
committee that probably don't
understand
uh charitable gaming
uh
in the minutia and we're never gonna get
through that this morning talking about
it so I I mean if we can give it a
peripheral kind of Rita's digest version
um
the state and it's in its wisdom some 10
or so years ago after years of back and
forth in relation to Lodge
uh you know traditional Casino gaming
chose to go the route that we have in
place now the model that we have in
place now which is the shareable gaming
rooms as we have them in New Hampshire
um with that
uh me being from Salem I've I've been
around it uh pretty much since it
started even before then and we can go
back to
you know the Bingo days when Bingo was
big
but
in incremental portions each year
charitable gaming has become most
importantly a great Revenue source for
our local charities a lot of these
charities
uh rely squarely rely on this Revenue to
do their service delivery to our
communities
what
what we have now for a for a model is
um some some of the operators choose to
call them casinos I guess it's a better
vernacular for advertisement or whatever
but we'll call them charitable casinos
I'll acknowledge that but we have all
sorts of gaming uh from Blackjack
roulette uh
and pretty much all the games you can
imagine uh poker
uh Spanish 21 all that stuff
and now as of last biennium we passed a
bill that allowed for historic horse
racing machines which is the latest
incremental step forward for these rooms
and with that legislation we allowed for
at present time prior to this each
charity was entitled to or could have 10
calendar days at a charitable gaming
facility
and utilize the revenue that was
generated in those 10 days in an effort
for their charities
with the passage of the HHR bill
uh last biennium we in fact doubled the
availability for Charities if a
charitable gaming room applies for and
it's and is approved to have historic
horse racing then instead of say 35
Charities having 10 days 10 days we
doubled it to 70. some of these rooms
will split them five days you know so at
present we probably have about 900 about
900 Charities local charities that are
getting revenue from these charitable
gaming rooms we have 14 charitable
gaming rooms in operation right now I
believe this is a 15th in the queue am I
correct
14 charitable gaming rooms as it stands
with a 15th uh
fitting up I guess
out of those
14 rooms in relation to HHR let me
double check here
um
not all of them are operating with HHR
at present
and I'm going to give you the number
because I have it here somewhere
I think there's uh in the neighborhood
of seven rooms that are still in process
waiting approval or haven't been
approved as of yet
so uh going back to the legislation last
year
in in the HHR bill
for instance
actually let me I'm getting ahead of
myself
so what what I we we have Set uh
percentages
for the state to Ghana revenue and for
the Cherry stagana revenue from the
charitable gaming model that we have
a lot of what is in this piece of
legislation and I sent around a copy I
had emailed you all a uh a copy of this
and this came from Rick Newman it was
great to to Bullet basically the changes
in this piece of legislation
um it's there's there's a lot of like
when I presented it there's a lot of
housekeeping stuff in here and we can go
through it item for item if we choose to
do so
and I'd be happy to answer any questions
in relation to
uh
my position on why I'm bringing this
forward but but a lot of it makes sense
a lot of it comes at the recommendation
of the lottery
and some of it like the
Max bet is bringing bringing it up to
par with what we have at present in the
state right now
the max maximum uh wage you can have in
a charitable gaming room is ten dollars
but yet we sell a 25 scratch ticket so I
see this bringing that Max bet to 25 as
a housekeeping initial
we can start with section one if we like
anybody get a question before I start
into this or
representative all me
and what's the difference between that
and awaiting approval
well it's my understanding and let me
see where I can find this and Lottery
can probably speak to it more
specifically but
as of now
eight of the rooms already have HHR
machines and seven have yet to apply are
yet to have been approved I guess it's
better stated
so you're just talking
what's this 15th Place that's in the
queue that we haven't we're always told
about 14. okay uh we we're talking about
North Conway
hopefully I would refer to because uh as
long as you just introduce who you are
and so forth so the committee knows that
Who You Are
the current law
there are two rooms in Hampton Beach one
runs in round one only runs in the
summer so I think when we talk about the
current 14 rooms for a currently 14
rooms like in the summertime
my misunderstanding
okay continue on
uh section one the changes if you if you
refer to the little cheat sheet I made
copies of
uh requirements a primary game operator
in secondary game operator licenses
um it this uh
this language is to I believe to clarify
at at present a primary game operator
is
being changed to standby to
game operator employer here's where I
get a little confused and I spoke to it
presenting the bill
um the primary game operator in in this
bill is going to be changed to the
primary basically the the uh proprietor
the the
license holder probably in most cases
instead of what's happening at present
you heard me speak of uh the the working
Foreman
that help run the room the The Pit
Bosses and and things of that nature
they're they're lumped into primary game
operators as it stands now as far as
licensing so this would clarify
uh and change primary game Operator 2
game operator employer
second
already just put on your light so I can
see thanks
uh representing to set isn't there I
seem to recall another section in law
where both of those terms are used and
defined so if we change it one place we
have to change it in others don't we
yeah there is hold on there's a
reference
bear with me
let me let me ask you
representative do you know specifically
where you're talking because I know that
there's
be careful with that question sir
no I don't know I just uh and perhaps uh
Mr Newman might know but I I remember
that or or maybe uh
the commissioner might know
um regarding its location but I I
thought we used that term didn't just
appear in one location it repaired up
here on in numerous locations
so I just wanted to make sure that if
we're going to change it one place we're
going to change it every place I got you
wait and to answer that there is uh
there's a certain fee and a time frame
as to those licenses and also in this
legislation it changes that licensing
from one year to three years in duration
okay with uh we'll we'll get to that but
I I know where you're coming from now
yeah
um representative only
thank you on
the game as I understand it we have
already a number of conglomerates from
outside of New Hampshire that are have
taken control of local
local parlors and
um
I'm looking at this and the owner of 10
or more of the entity partner managing
member or chief executive who serves as
a game operator employer
uh must be listed on the game operator
license application rather than licensed
himself
as one
and does this make it harder to evaluate
any kind of Mafia
involvement
in
in these these places that are being
developed
when you're only listing them rather
than licensing them
I would defer it to Lottery on that one
I notice he's wincing at me
director McIntyre if you would like to
comment you don't have to it's totally
up to you you're here
yeah
probably something
so
let me find out
yeah and the person that's just the case
it's a question
um
I have no idea
um representative orrs can you ask our
assistant if we are streaming this I
assume we are because this is a noticed
meeting
if we are being streamed then we would
ask that if you're going to answer a
question that you probably should come
up to the microphone because otherwise I
don't think people can see you or hear
you so
so just so we completely transparent on
everything we're doing okay we are being
live stream so yes next time uh come on
up
okay so could I representative always
what so what is the process and is it
going to change for people that
businesses or individuals or contacts
that
that are
on
have bought more than 10 percent
of
the operation
of the Brooks or whatever
forget I said the books since you're not
allowed to talk about individual ones
so so basically we look at the LLC
generally that is the owner of the game
operator and within that LLC we're going
to look at anybody associated with that
LLC
um to a 10 level and deeper if we feel
that it needs to go deeper
in this bill just clarifies this is it
you guys know I'm in this industry a
little bit so this I think just
clarifies who goes in what category with
these different titles it's because a
little confusing right now I think and
so this is just trying to clarify that
the game operator employer is the
business is that correct
correct me if I'm wrong because the
language talks about Indian individuals
and yes but I also um to the question to
Fred about the primary versus the game
operator what happened was
prior to the game operator employer
designation the rule used to just refer
to a primary when they added game
operator employer they forgot to remove
the references to the primary in some
sections so it doesn't make sense so
that's why they're being removed in
places because it's really the primary
game operator that has those
responsibilities
representative black I didn't understand
what does a 10 level mean
10 ownership oh okay ownership okay
follow on please follow up yeah there
was a reference by another rep about uh
potential for people of ill repute
getting into the business wouldn't they
be more likely to attack them go after
the major casinos in other states as
opposed to these charitable game
operations were limited size
um I could tell you it was a prior life
representative I was an organized crime
prosecutor and they don't tend to go
after anything like this the review
process is
um remarkably onerous
remarkably onerous and we've had a
number of applicants
withdraw based on that
so
I didn't make you an author you couldn't
refuse
even when I was a prosecutor they didn't
sadly you know representative all me
yes and could you give us an idea of
what disqualifies somebody
um
a criminal blemish a financial blemish
having a for example bankruptcy
um
a conviction that related to
um less than best of being honest for
example like if you were charged with
larceny or a bad check
um
I don't want to get into specifics
because that it would be like I said
violating the state law but essentially
it's a review and candidly we're not the
reviewing agency We Are The Gatherer of
information
based on the past law the session you
folks proved our investigation and
enforcement division does the review
would stash with ex-police officers and
Auditors who do a review of the
financial history criminal history
Etc and that document is it's not a
document it's a very large pack of
information it's past the attorney
general and he reviews it himself and so
um that process takes a long time
all right I think I saw some hands over
here representative Schamberg
yes and mine is more on financial if you
want to continue on with
what we're discussing I
yeah I mean it's up to the pleasure of
the committee we can keep going through
the Section by section or if I can make
a suggestion if we go through this
section by section we're never going to
make Headway at all so I think every
pretty much committee's had a chance to
review it if they have questions it's
probably uh do you want to just do a
high level overview of a
basically what this does is it it
Narrows down the fees for the employees
and the time frames for which the
employees have to be licensed so so if
somebody is dealing Blackjack they have
to apply to Lottery go through the
clearances pay out of pocket for these
licenses on an annual basis this would
allow for them to do it every three
years but they file an affidavit if
there's a change in their status if
they're convicted of something at l
okay but follow-up Madam chair but going
to the Lawson licensing Revenue
overall when you change from a one year
to a three year
why are we reducing the
fee like in the facility from uh 250 a
year for the 14 facilities to 83 83 33
every year
are they losing money
is that why the the fee is being reduced
for over those three-year periods
I think you're talking about the
Charities fee
the Charities fee how much the charity
is paying for their license dates is
going down
right is that there's a component in
there for the facility license also
which page are we talking about
well uh
I look at the game operator employers
they have a three year period from a
date of issue and
the proposed fee will be 750 for the
three-year period equal to 250 a year
but for each year there were 750.
I I just looking at the loss of revenue
for the state
uh maybe I
I see a point representative and agree
with your point but when it when it
comes to the employees paying out of
pocket I I do have issue because
everybody's having the same issue with
uh recruitment retention
um and the fact that a lot of these
folks that work these rooms are jumping
through hoops a lot of them work in
different rooms and supplement their
income that way work a couple different
rooms but uh you know that's something
we can look at keeping the game operator
license the same
now I think I see what you're looking at
so you're looking at this latest handout
with the fiscal impact so if you look at
page three of five and you'll see
there's a little table there which gives
the current for the different types of
licenses versus the proposed in the bill
and what the fiscal impact will be and
so what I was mentioning is the the most
notable
but is the charity reduction because
right now they pay twenty five dollars
per game day
and then this would propose that would
pay a straight dollar amount for a
10-day period is that correct okay
so
okay well yeah go ahead I'm surprised
um and
let's see so so also I spoke briefly
about raising the uh the maximum wage
limit to 25 uh coupled with that is a uh
a section nine that talks about removing
the requirement the prize is above 500
be paid by check
um and also increases the tournament
buy-in to twenty five hundred dollars
from the current 250 dollars and and
what what I'm shooting at with that I I
try to play poker on on a Monday I enjoy
playing poker if I can get out I I play
and I like to play tournament poker
especially when they used to have it at
Rockingham Park
and it drives a lot of business for
these uh Casino rooms these charitable
gaming rooms which the peripheral
business from the poker tournaments uh
adds Revenue to the pot for the
Charities and the state
um this would allow for and I don't
suspect by any stretch of the
imagination so the the biggest uh
tournament tournaments in the state are
obviously 250 I think they've run them
maybe once a month month a couple of the
rooms do that but this allows for the
availability for if there's a special
you know like on a Super Bowl Sunday or
a special date and they wanted to do a
larger buy-in a 500 tournament or a
thousand dollar tournament these poker
plays on one of them will travel I'll go
to Foxwoods I'm contemplating going to
New York for a satellite kind of
tournament
that they have for the World Series of
Poker out there but I'm a little
committed to what we're doing here right
now so you know it's it's something that
I enjoy and I think uh that would drive
Revenue peripherally around the rooms
hotels and stuff like that and some of
these bigger operations would would do
well with that it just
gives them the opportunity to to have
the option to run a 500 tournament if
they chose to do so
uh
a lot of these changes were suggested by
Lottery and I don't know if anything
another question Madam chair
the lottery
Mr McIntyre I see on a summary
that uh
the suggestion of raising the bond from
a million to from 500 000 to a million
was recommended by the lottery
uh but you're removing the certificate
of good standing by the dra requirement
well why is that
so the requirement for the dra was put
in several years ago and it it's
difficult for the dra to process those
quickly so we're often just waiting for
them and they really don't provide us
with information that's really needed to
vet and and license a game room
follow-up
is your investigative technique
different or just do you have a faster
system or what do you have that's
different the dra isn't doing an
investigation so we're doing a thorough
investigation and the dra portion is not
particularly valuable to our assessment
oh and the bond we've increased the bond
because many of our well at least one of
our room is hitting that 500 000 cap
already and as we get HHR and whatnot
it's expected to go higher so we need a
higher cap to cover what we base the
bond on is three months worth of
obligations what they would owe to the
state and the Charities and so we want
to make sure there's enough in that bond
to cover three months worth
yes representative Ellery
while you're discussing the bond
could you explain to us uh
how that works I know how it works uh
under my license
and I want to make sure that it works
the same under yours under your scheme
so basically if there's a violation
um we could we could get the bond but
we're mostly doing that and I don't know
that we've ever done it but it would
mostly be if they suddenly went out of
business and didn't pay the Charities of
the state that's what we need the bond
for
so the bond
is a methodology an insurance policy
because you buy it through insurance
companies that pays for when you screw
up so you're paying for your own
screw-up in advance
just
Elber
thank you madam chair I apologize for
not having this information
um but can you give us I I remember
seeing the pie chart but I don't
remember the numbers of the total
profits coming in uh to the casino's
um
game charitable gaming and the total
number to the State education fund and
the total number to charities
so that information obviously changes
month by month I don't have an updated
number to hand you but I certainly we
can get you one because we wouldn't know
you asked the question regarding profits
we would only know Revenue so the
operator themselves we would know what
portion they were able to keep we would
not know what was profit so but we can
get you an updated numbers in terms of
each
um
each area
we have every month we
've on our on our website which is
connected to the main lottery one we
have what we call market trends which
gives out some of that Revenue data
thank you I'm
question I don't know if this is a
question or a comment for representative
Doucet or members of the lottery but
um
we heard earlier today oplc uh was here
and I know this is not related to oplc
but I think that there's something I
want to comment on and that's the
potential for
the legislative intent that we're
talking about today and and that we have
in front of us is one thing and I think
we're all going to come to a discussion
here we're having a good discussion here
but looking at section four section five
there's a couple of other areas in there
that I worry
that we may want to tighten up on
um for instance in section four uh it's
repealed and reenacted to read as
follows if you look at line number 14.
requirements of RSA 287 D5 provided that
the commission may by rule establish
additional items to be submitted on the
application form or attached to it and
that phrase is used several times
throughout the bill
um you look going on line 27 the Lottery
Commission made by rule establish
additional items to be submitted on the
application form attached to it
the thing that I worry about is that you
know we have legislation that is going
to
um
we're going to may or may not take
action on on this but hopefully we we
can get to some resolution here but that
comment by rule
I just worry if that's opening up a back
door
for and I'm not making any accusation uh
um I'm not this is not but I I've seen
it I've experienced it where
rules kind of take on a life of
themselves
and can kind of grow and turn into this
big thing that we didn't anticipate
could I I apologize I lost you can you
go give us page number and line numbers
page page two
um and we're on Section Five but it was
mentioned on section four as well so
it's page two line 14.
page two
line 27
uh page two line 35
um and I don't know if maybe we want to
to to to be a little more
prescriptive in what we expect out of
the rules
uh rather than just leave the door open
for
four rules
and I'm not not making any comments on
the Lottery's ability to write rules but
having been on the receiving end of this
having listened to testimony from oplc
which has kind of turned into a
rule-making uh octopus
um
it's just a comment
so can I just when you do this is it by
rule through gel car or what did that
mean
because usually it would say that's the
process yeah so I mean if that needs to
be added
so go ahead yes if I'd even follow up I
mean I and I don't know if how Orthodox
this is but
I would love to have you as the primary
sponsor to be able to take a look at
whatever rule comes out just to make
sure it's consistent with what your
intent was with with the law
um you know I think that's one of the
things you know having working in in a
board
we struggle oftentimes with what the
legislative intent is and as years go on
and things change the legislative intent
is kind of lost but if we can have a you
you have the input from the primary
sponsor on the rule then we would know
that the legislative intent is
is there and we're comfortable with with
that I mean that's again I've never seen
that done
um but I know somebody who works on the
rule side for us is frustrated sometimes
with the fact that uh you know things
can kind of grow and and and and and and
the intent is ultimately lost over time
anything else on that yeah
representative Ames
just
to comment on that I I think that um
I guess we all have to make our choices
but the nature of legislation like this
is that it assigns to the agency
Authority within specified parameters
and then there's a rule making process
that's defined very carefully in the
state law that involves a public review
and comment and the the frame that the
agency has to work within is the
legislation and then there are the you
know the statute of the what the prime
sponsor may or may not have said in my
experience is is not the final word and
what the meaning of the legislation is
um you know there may have been reports
in the calendar on the bill when it went
through that maybe more interesting but
uh but there are a whole lot of law
around
around this and I think maybe you're
talking more about how much do you want
to delegate to the to the agency I can
understand that discussion I do think
for
for a situation like this where we've
got a very experienced agency that's
worked through the rule making process
time and time again
um
and uh you know there's always going to
be some dispute as to whether they went
too far or didn't go far enough but
they've done so as far as I can tell
good jobs so I wouldn't want to over
specify and try to do that I think that
would be a mistake and you know maybe
there's a particular suggestion that
you'd have on a particular one of these
um areas that you've identified
but that's my background I I used to
write rules in Massachusetts for some
big agencies so I've been through both
sides of this thing I I know they're
there's never going to be a good answer
and in the end you get down to details
that nobody's thought of
representative fellows
um yes I'd kind of like to
look at the financial part of this
is it is it your expectation that we
will have more facilities
seeking licenses
if we pass this
well no as the bill reads now section 18
um
blocks any future facilities from being
available which would limit obviously
the market and competition
so the answer is no quite the opposite
yeah you would you would be codifying
for permanently a Prohibition on
expansion
specifically to HHR yeah I didn't say
anything about HH oh sorry that's sort
of a yeah so
when I see
no because you would have seen one
before this the it's been an open market
for a number of years and
the number of applications has not grown
dramatically
yeah so so is there no limitation right
now on more forget about the HHR yes
your facilities there's no limitation on
the correct there's no limitation but
when you if we were to raise
the betting limit
wouldn't that make it more profitable to
operate and so because of that we might
see more
I'm sure that's possible like and I'll
use the example um blackjack
Blackjack a dealer minimally has to do
30 deals an hour in order to be
profitable at this current rate if a
higher wager was allowed particularly on
a
you're not going to get a 25 bet on
Tuesday afternoon that's for Friday and
Saturday nights that would make it more
profitable correct for the house as well
as the dealers they do better with
higher wage limits because it increases
their tip count
represents did you have anything else to
represent Ames
okay
representative I was letting in Valley
came over here too I was letting people
air out it there's although I share
representative rofit's frustration and
I've shared that with you in the rules
making process this this is current law
so it's not changing anything that's not
currently in place
okay representative said you want to
continue with high level if yeah if I
can elaborate on this and and
representative fellows asked a great
question What in in section 19 of this
uh sorry section 18 of this we we at
present
uh with with the passage of HHR
uh Last by Anna worked in a a moratorium
date of I believe it's July is it July
one yeah July 1 of 2024.
um that was in part to
allow for lottery to get up and running
allow for The Operators to get up and
running allow for the charity list to
grow and and to be filled and all the
um the minutia work uh the work through
gel car and and setting the rules and
whatnot
um that process took a little more than
some of us a little more time than some
of us expected
and the the subsequent uh result of that
and representative Ami touched on it is
there's been some massive interests
because of this particular component in
our charitable gaming although not a
slot machine
they they have
I didn't say anyone called it a slot
machine but although not a slot machine
the electronic gaming is driving Revenue
and some big operators have come in and
bought up some of the rooms
and we don't see a lot of applications
and I'll stand corrected if Lottery
tells us otherwise applications for
charitable gaming rooms but I can tell
you personally that I'm getting a lot of
incoming because I'm from Salem and
Salem is seems to be one of those places
much like Nashua probably Seabrook
border towns that get targeted for this
type of business
I don't think we'll see an influx of
people applying our entities employ
applying for gaming licenses until after
this moratorium
and I think
we have the ability
maybe to put that in check this this
particular component keeps in place the
15 current rooms 14 15 current rooms to
be available to offer HHR gaming
it does not allow and when I presented
this legislation to the committee we at
president have those 14 15 rooms in the
state of New Hampshire and the whole of
New England there are nine in total
casinos in New England we we at
president have 14 and one pot time
Casino 15 casinos in New Hampshire I for
one coming from where I come from in the
history of what went on as far as the
back and forth of uh big Casino gaming
in in the subsequent model that we have
now
I don't want to be
in a position where at least in the town
of Salem we're turning that place into a
little Atlantic City that's that's not
what New Hampshire is
we're not about gaming this is a great
component for our Charities I think
Lottery does an outstanding job
getting the product out
um
enforcing what needs to be enforced and
helping those revenues get out to the
Charities to deliver the services I just
believe it's time that we take a step
back and say maybe maybe we don't want
HHR Barnes popping up on every corner as
I spoke to in my presentation I have a
place in Nova Scotia you can walk into
any
it seems like any restaurant whatever in
this gaming everywhere I I don't want
the state of New Hampshire to look like
that so I think we have to take a solid
look at the fact that maybe we should
put some limitations on this and I don't
know that the the July 1 of 24 date is
going to be any measure for us
to look back and say well hhr's working
here or maybe it needs to be tweaked
there I think with the slower rollout
than expected to these rooms for that
particular component I think we need a
longer look at it and my suggestion is
we stop it at 15 rooms and we don't
allow for these things to pop up
everywhere
representative Ames
so I guess I'm a little confused don't I
um and maybe this is obvious but if
section 18 of this bill is enacted
um that will
do I understand this correctly that will
mean
that they will remain a limit
of 14.
of these HHR facilities
without limitation going forward is that
correct correct okay the the and let me
specify Lottery deems as to how many uh
machines can be
in in a facility via the size of the
facility by percentage of table games
and others so it's not like somebody can
come in and buy a hundred thousand
square foot place and put machines in it
that's that's not the case whatsoever
um
my question to you is uh why not
if you're concerned that maybe this
doing away with this limit is premature
why why not propose
delay for a couple of years of the
um
a decision on whether or not to continue
this limit
that's a great question representative
and and I guess I'm looking from and we
spoke a little earlier from the
perspective of the interest and the
interests that have already come in and
bought some of these smaller operations
I think um
if if we were to add a few more years
onto it we'd have a better measure and a
better look at the impact of that but
again we'll be sitting here
talking about this the same issue I feel
because there are going to be more of
that if if this is as profitable as we
projected last biennium
that I mean the cat's out of the bag
these these big players are coming in
and buying these rooms up it's not going
to stop there so
let's set the mark let's set the limit
as a state as to how much gaming and and
in moreover if if we don't allow for
that it it lessens the pool for these
Charities that count on these dollars
too if they stop popping up these
smaller sites
they're going to take away for instance
Salem's Lucky in that
that room is pretty profitable it does
not have HHR but it's a very profitable
room so some I'll say 35 Charities some
of them are the Legacy Charities going
back to
06 or earlier that literally build out
everything they do for the community
from these dollars if five more rooms
were to pop up in Salem
that the available dollars for those
core Charities to the community you know
they'll be scrambling you know what
charities are going to fill these slots
I mean Lottery does a phenomenal job I
believe these operators do a phenomenal
job with their charity coordinators and
we've all heard the testimony from the
Charities that come in and tell us the
impact of these dollars
I think that
the industry you know when is saturation
point for the industry too
I definitely don't want be and want to
be you know uh Atlantic City North
up here this is still New Hampshire so
and you know I'm a very pro-gaming guy
but there's there's a there's a limit to
everything
representative Schamberg
just a quick question to you um
what's your understanding of the
demand to
um
open more facilities
um So currently there are the number is
the number right there are eight
operating with HHR there are others in a
Queue at various stages
um and there are approximately 1200
machines in place in the state
the plurality are in Seabrook not quite
half
Seabrook the brook
um
I would submit I think soon but I don't
know when we'll hit a place where
there'll be saturation without even this
expansion
but candidly um I often I think we said
that saturation is probably two two
thousand of these things across the
state the bulk of which would be if the
market dictated would be in Rockham
Hillsborough County
um not because the most people in the
State live there but because it's closer
to where more people in Massachusetts
and uh Encore is not a friendly place to
visit in terms of a customer it's hard
to get to parking's not great traffic is
ridiculous
um
and so
I think as soon as the others come
online I think you're going to hit a
saturation point of the state by the
same token you know I think we're free
market folks and would the market would
dictate where they're going how uh as
representative Jose said there are
things in place that we put in through
rule that limit the size of these places
meaning there has to be so much square
footage dedicated to floors dedicated to
machines
that the max amount of Revenue can
exceed more than 6.3 times the table
Revenue so that there's the balance of
what it looks like as well as what the
Charities receive a revenue so as he has
he suggested there's no ability to
airdrop a thousand of these things into
an abandoned Sears the limits are there
moreover the cost to stand one of these
things up on its own is in the mid seven
figures because of our requirements for
controls
anti-money laundering surveillance
floors
the licensing through not licensing the
certification through the laboratory
it's it's a complicated process so that
has a natural barrier to things all
those elements
representative thank you madam chair uh
representative Doucette I compliment you
on on the charity reduction
so that they get more the on their fee
when they file you know what was it 50 a
year okay and the sgo
the single you know the game
how about the pgo the goe and the
facility are those
people that do not have any money when
they come into this or they can't afford
the like the two the facility 250 a year
they can't afford whoever owns that
facility
um
uh could be a big owner
uh if they own 10 I'm sure they can
afford to 250 a year times three and I'm
sure the goe the game operator can
afford the 750 a year
I just wonder why those are reduced for
those three areas
and and thank you for the question and
you're welcome as as stated earlier I
agree with you I agree with you I I just
saw lowering fees as
the thing to do I think most
specifically the most important
component of this in all seriousness is
the Feast of the charities in in the
work of bees let's make it easier to go
to work
on Monday and not have to worry about
paying to do that work I'm going to
agreement with you and and I would I
guess I would ask Lottery too does does
this reflect on your does it help you in
any way only having to license these
these folks every three years I'm
talking about the dealers and the in The
Pit Bosses and whatnot
just want to make a correction to I did
the fiscal impact and I did it thinking
that it was one fee to cover the
three-year period
but Mr Newman pointed out to me that no
it's the same fee every year
they're just not having to submit for a
criminal background check that's really
what this does the only reduction
actually in the fees has to do with the
primary game operator I believe it was
500 and it's down to 100 now those are
basically your Pit Bosses and the
Charities it used to be twenty five
dollars per game date now it's a solid
fifty dollar regardless of how many game
dates you have
just uh interject here and I failed to
when they filed that affidavit annually
they pay Lottery the fee
but they don't have to pay the extra 75
bucks to have their fingerprints checked
they attest the uh the affidavit and
go back on checks almost 25 20 25 but
whatever okay it saves them some money
and and it it frees up some some time
for lottery I would think and I I would
imagine that
if something were to come to pass in in
a three-year spin that they would find
out and they they have to attest to
these affidavits it just
smoother operation
I I will just mention as an employer
um hiring is hard and we're hiring
dealers a lot of them in New Hampshire
we have to train ourselves because
they're not there's not a lot of other
casinos you have to train them so you
know to get them to apply to get them
trained is quite a big deal and then to
have them go through a lot of Hoops and
a lot of expense to get their license is
is hard so anything we could do for the
for them would be wonderful yes
representative ulery
regarding fingerprinting
it's my understanding they don't change
much
so and the question is did you or safety
retain the fingerprints
safety would be the better person to
answer this question but it's my
understanding that no after a certain
brief period I think it's like 30 days
they don't maintain them after that
period
follow-up
so if we were to put a clause in here
that says retain for three years
or retain for as long as they have a
license
then you'd have those fingerprints on
file at all times you wouldn't need to
redo them all the time you wouldn't and
if they're not keeping them for very
long they're useless because they're
only there for 30 days
so if if a carve out for retention of
these fingerprints or it's included in
this and somebody else had to do it and
by the way the only place they're wiped
out of is conquered not where they were
sent down to be checked in Washington
they're still on file down there believe
me
um
so I'm just trying to get around this
concern about having uh uh somebody
bypassing it's not it's not the it's not
the fingerprint so much that to keep on
file it's more going through the
criminal background check and I can tell
you it's a huge hardship for the dealers
and the Charities who
um you know they haven't done anything
wrong nothing changes over time but they
are going they're going to attest that
nothing has changed and then every three
years they'll go through the whole
process again
it's not the fingerprint so much it's
the criminal background check would you
agree yeah okay yeah
when I had my PI license
we had to have it's 25 for the criminal
background check
and that's the state one it's 75 if you
would do the multi-state uh ncic uh
check uh which should or should not uh
it may or may not I should say include a
uh a provinces check through RCMP but
it's only because we're close
um
and we did that every two years
as part of the the fee but then again
arrive investigators are doing some
stuff that deals directly with people as
opposed to Mere Money to your point
representative I mean these these folks
are on camera 24 7. so when they're
dealing there's never the issue in terms
of the activity because they're
surveilled
um we'll go back to video so the
activity is less
um intrusive in the pis license yeah I I
want to uh be in the uh control room
because then I can make sure I know what
I'm getting uh
yeah just so you know our dealers and
our staff are highly regulated you know
watched constantly if there's any
aberration it's looked at I mean this is
really tight because we do believe that
we're stewards of Charity money and
state money so we we are very very
careful
um so to have people go through a full
criminal background check every year is
it's I don't know it's a little bit
demoralizing for some of our Charities
especially many of whom who run these
local charities or Bank presidents and
they don't have to go through a criminal
Jam Echo and check for that so it is it
does seem excessive and I know it's it's
hard on lottery staff to be chasing all
this stuff all the time it's just like a
huge paperwork
thing so
all right anything else you wanted to
highlight
you know one thing I just should mention
if you know I'm just being transparent
here you guys know I've got a little
place down the street you know we work
very hard to make money for Charities
and keep the lights on but we don't
always make money every day it is it's
gaming and there were days several days
a month maybe that the operator loses
money just so you know
um but over the 10-day period of course
the Charities are held completely
harmless but over the 10-day period the
Charities always make money the state
always makes money and we get to keep
the lights on but I recently this came
to my attention so I just want to be
transparent about it that there was a
change in a form that that we fill out
every month and if we lost money on a
day we didn't have to pay the tax but
now the way the form has changed we're
paying taxes on a zero Revenue day while
I have you here is that something
you can comment on or that's probably
best discussed outside since it's
particular to your game operator oh okay
I've heard this from other operators so
I'm just like I didn't know where that
came from I have been given the comment
I am going to be looking at it but I
can't answer that right okay great this
is I've heard this not just myself but
just just want to make sure that I'm
being transparent okay anything else on
this bill
yes representative prep I just say I'm
treasurer of lion sight and hearing
Foundation of New Hampshire and we
received a thirty thousand dollars which
has gone to a purchase of uh of ice
cleaners so we go into schools and I
won't call it a camera because parents
freak it's a screener it automatically
takes a picture it tells anything wrong
that might be wrong with a kid and it
comes out with needs referral and we
refer through the school nurse and we've
caught a lot of cases of kids who
couldn't see well
including one who had cancer behind the
eye we caught
anything else on this yes representative
liebly
um sorry this is a um I just have two
things one the if we're thinking about
the worker I guess have a couple of
thoughts one like when you hire could
make part of your hiring like we'll pay
your fees for this right
um it does say that the
the person if they're dealing for a
variety of places they would have to
have a different badge for each place
which seems like if they're paying the
licensing fee they are licensed to do
something like they should have a badge
that says this is who I am I'm licensed
to do this why do they have to have
um multiple badges
so they would pay one application fee
and and currently it's different but
under this change they would pay one
application fee the badge fee is ten
dollars it's just so that they have one
that gives the game room because each
each employer that they're working for
is going to want us their game room
specified on their name badge so they'll
be licensed like you said for wherever
but they'll need a badge that says so
for that particular room
which seems weird to charge the employee
to advertise for their employer but if
that's how it's done I guess that's how
it's done
um it looks like two I'm just looking at
the
the internet as we're sitting here and
it looks like the two proposed new
gaming uh
Charities one in Lebanon one in Concord
are one is 17 000 square feet that's
being proposed and one is
um 24 000 square feet how does that
compare with the size of the places that
we're talking about in Salem
this sounds big to me
those are obviously big but those aren't
new licenses those are current licensed
holders that are applying if you're
looking into buying a different property
and expanding their operation and I'm
sure the
director can speak to it certainly
um
compared to certain facilities they're
they're large like for example if you
compare it to Berlin Berlin's very small
but others they're actually much much
smaller then when you compare it to a
normal size Casino it's dwarfed okay I'd
make the MGM comparison it's like the
difference between a lion and a kitten
in terms of size difference they're very
small because a lot of that facility to
be sure we require a significant table
presence as part of their license and
also the surveillance room account rooms
there's significant back office
facilities that absorb a lot of space
so 70 000 square feet seems like a lot
but it's not as big as you'd think once
you get to when you walked in and see
what the floor would look like
so to go back to the question
14 and limiting you know whatever the
number is 14 15. it it are we talking
about limiting
the game room number or the licensees
because if these are being opened by
people who already hold a license
couldn't they open
multiple new rooms no it was our
interpretation and it's been enforced
personally by me that said no if there
was one facility that's through one
facility and you can move it under the
provisions of the prior law within the
jurisdiction so if it was within
concrete could stay within Concord to go
someplace else uh representative
doucet's Town Salem has Provisions that
say it could only go in certain places
some jurisdictions have those
restrictions so they can only go in res
you know industry a for example
um but that would limit it it's not like
you can split off and there's no
so just to clarify I'm understanding
right so the new place in Lebanon if it
opens yes it's not an additional place
they had it over here they're moving it
over here to expand or for whatever
correct so okay to make sure so that
you're clear I'm clear to your clear
um that's for historic horse racing as
for games of chance as we said before
there's no limit on the applications
that can be for that
but a games your chance license would
have to go with the new HHR location and
would only be one
and the bill in front of us is limiting
HHR only correct okay thank you
and and to my to my argument if if there
was going to be an influx of of people
who wanted open charitable gaming rooms
they would be right now would happen
right now but my suspicion and fear is
when we hit that July one date of 24
then all bets are off so
best offer defense is a good offense
representative almond did you have your
hand up
I I could comment on the Lebanon thing
it's a very small room now I don't know
how they fit in both machines and poker
tables frankly and I some people say
that there's almost nobody in it and
other people say that some days it's
crowded but it's a former Honda dealer
down the street from me
and it's one building off from the
largest thrift store in our region
which I don't especially appreciate but
it's there it is uh what I wanted to ask
about was uh technical or mechanical
defects this building this bill was not
amended when it left Edna they just sent
it here
was this bill any DNA I don't think
no I don't think
um
oh no this one this one
did we get this first why are we
discussing it now
just because there was a lot of
questions no but what I mean is we
didn't start to know about this bill
until very recently
well we did the original hearing on this
what two three weeks ago and February
9th super steering was okay so now we're
just doing follow-up with all the bills
there was lots of questions on I figured
we'd okay there's a whole lots of
technical or mechanical defects they
wanted corrected and
somebody ought to pay some attention to
those there is put our fiscal
representative we submitted what we
thought were technical defects with the
bill
um the fiscal note for us we I think I'd
apologize my are probably hearing we
submitted this the day the day of the
hearing last time so these what what our
suggested technical changes to the bill
yeah only a few of us got it okay so the
what we handed out today that's what
we're talking about is the technical
things we need to look at okay final
okay page
four
is there five don't have five
okay so there's only four okay so
okay so we do need to read through these
probably and uh
representative just said do you want to
take a look at these a little bit more
detail and just see what we need to do
okay great
thank you anything else awesome okay we
will stop the work session on House Bill
for nope 607
and we will
go to house bill
486.
production
s
beautiful
okay 486 is relative to Vehicle
registrations and reciprocal toll
collection enforcement agreements
we had a public hearing on
January 31st going way back
uh there was a lot of questions
um
I asked representative orrs to take a
little more of a detailed look at it and
love to hear what you learned and then
kind of go from there and learn see what
we are do you want to tell us what you
think yes okay thank you madam chair
I want to offer a special thanks to
representative ulrey for volunteering me
for this task
and I wanted to congratulate the rest of
you for hanging in here all day and you
get to you get the we saved the best for
last let me just put it that way how's
that
Okay so
uh I believe HB 486 is inexpedient to
legislate
to do anything other than to I believe
Leaf things as they are is gonna hurt
D.O.T and DMV's collection of tolls and
fines and so on
uh in addition to that we have
a fee schedule that I've learned the
initial fine is fifty dollars if it ever
goes that far
it isn't the 250 dollars that
the representative that sponsored the
bill initially said so that was that was
just an error I'm sure
I could not confirm that anywhere with
DLT or DMV
I did try to contact the representative
that sponsored the bill and uh my
request for information was not returned
so we're looking at several points here
until violations toll collection
notification and eventually DMV and
suspension
after uh I did not get a response I did
go back and watch the the
sponsor of the bill I watched their
testimony and John cochranes from D.O.T
I believe that
the system could be improved
and Improvement would basically be
eliminating the system altogether
the other Improvement that could be done
which is already being done is instead
of 20 manual
requests for payment a month of the
other states the system is being
automated uh it's currently pretty much
done with Massachusetts and they're
testing it and so on
and Maine is a few months further behind
personal notification seems to be very
adequate
it was testified that the representative
son or young adult teenage son or young
adult went through the toll booth one
time and got fined 250
Etc
this does not seem to be the case I'm
sure the world can turn upside down and
accidents do happen however
if it did happen it was a one-off
so the way to process actually works is
once there are 10 violations a
notification goes out
and they have 30 days to respond
after that
30 days a second notification goes out
on a pink card
and the reason for the pink card is to
get their attention
make sure that they've seen the
notification
if 30 days go by and there's no response
there is a third notification which
takes approximately 30 days
it is 30 days
if there's no response the fourth
notification
they get is 30 days so now we're up to
120 days and
along with that the DMV process to
suspend the registration begins however
nothing is done it just it sets it up
like an Excel spreadsheet you're going
to work on and do a project or whatever
it just sets it up
then if in 30 days
there is no response that's when the DMV
suspension comes into play and of course
the individual would not know their
suspension is going to be
forthcoming unless they either read the
notifications or had some idea as to
what's going on in their life or
whatever
so we are at the 150 day Mark minimum
considering that there may be time in
between each of those 30 note day
notifications of a couple days maybe
part of a week whatever
so in conclusion the DMV's whole line of
registration is definitely not targeting
the occasional tow Violator
based on my review and in my experience
DMV is targeting habitual toll violators
that accumulate approximately five
hundred dollars plus or minus
in delinquent tolls
now it's beyond the scope I'm sure of
the committee in my time and so on and
so forth for me to go in person and do a
personal audit which normally I would do
if I was doing an audit
in this case I think the
information I've received
and being an auditor you may have seen
me a couple times question people in
here and sometimes I got a little
carried away and I apologize for that
I believe I've covered this like 14 Ways
to Sunday I've peeled back the onion and
I don't think there's anything left on
the table again I could have missed
something somebody could have lied to me
I don't think D.O.T
would lie to me I don't think DMV would
I think they're very forthcoming I think
they're actually fantastic organization
the way they operate and my hat's off to
them for the way they do this whole
operation again I don't think it can be
improved unless a we get the Automation
and b or we just canceled the whole toll
Easy Pass system altogether entirely
thank you I think you've generated some
questions yes representative Platt yes
thank you for taking my question Madam
chair do I have to take questions
all right
discussion
I forgot what I'm gonna say
representative hands representative
thank you it had two quick questions one
the way you describe it sounds like a
very operational uh system that would
work uh personal experience with them
and for getting to move my transponder
from vehicle to vehicle uh it's not the
way that they operate uh number two did
you discuss with them the corruption
that exists that has been made very
obvious in the Press regarding uh
suspension of uh registrations for
violating Massachusetts or Maine toll
provisions
uh so excuse me what was your first
point your experience doesn't follow
doesn't comport with uh what the rules
are uh when I get a uh Pink the first
notification spank and it's six months
after and that's the only notification
received but that's personal experience
and that's with legislative plates on uh
second issue was regarding the
well-publicized problems that both Main
and Mass
uh have regarding their uh their
operations and their demands to suspend
the registrations of New Hampshire
residents
so the your first point
in my experience I have gone through the
tolls I went through three or four I was
discussing this with uh Rhett brochure
today and
it picked up my transponder on one did
it on the second it did on the third and
if there was a fourth it also picked
that up
within a week I had a picture of me
obviously driving the car
my car plates and everything and here's
my here's my fee I think it was like
twenty one dollars in change
I picked up the phone called the EZ Pass
system the 800 number I think it was
within a couple of minutes I had
somebody on the line
I explained to them what happened they
checked
their system and they said you're good
we cleared it all said and done so like
I said earlier in my pitch
like anything else in life especially in
the world of automation there could be a
one-off
but okay you're shaking your head and
also yeah I can't speak to that now as
for the corruption in the mass in Maine
and as far as collecting tolls I am on
the take so I can no I'm just kidding
I just wanted to see if anybody was
paying attention
so that that subject never came up I
have not heard of that I don't know how
that would impact the individual in
terms of paying a fine of fifty dollars
or whatever but are you saying that
they're using this as blackmail
no um Massachusetts if you evade the
tolls in Massachusetts on the Easy Pass
system they have the ability to spend
your registration in New Hampshire just
like New Hampshire has the ability to
suspend the registration of a
Massachusetts resident for evading New
Hampshire yes I believe that is correct
so the problem with Massachusetts which
re I think they fired one director and
they had to redo their entire thing
there are literally
millions of dollars sitting out there
someplace uh which hasn't been really
taken care of because
well it's Massachusetts and Maine
views the same system
for a long time so
I won't mention names or companies but
as an auditor a young auditor has handed
a file worth millions of dollars I was
told to bury that file and I did I
buried it right where I could find it
and after I looked at it and the
Auditors came through about six months
later
I handed that filed to the Auditors
explain the situation and in less than a
year the vice president and the
president and Company were fired
so corruption corruption is out there
but that doesn't mean we're going to
throw the baby out with the bathwater
follow up
point is
is I believe that was the uh the Bill's
author point is we shouldn't be
subjecting New Hampshire residents
to abuse by a foreign state
because of their problems I I absolutely
absolutely agree and the same would go
for our own state New Hampshire
in this situation as far as I can tell
unless I was to go in and do an audit
it appears that this system it doesn't
introduce the first fine
until after 150 days notification and
it's not until after 90 days
notification does the if you want to
call it a ticket as I mentioned earlier
the possible if you think of it as an
Excel spreadsheet
for suspension this started
so
I don't know if your Situation's one-off
the corruption obviously is sounds to me
like it's well publicized but I am not
aware of it and the fact that corruption
could exist all shocking off the
government's involved
so
as far as I can tell though a fine of
fifty dollars I mean I started I went to
OLS I had an amendment drafted up to
start to find a 300 and end the fine at
three hundred dollars thinking that what
we were told initially to find for 250
500 and a thousand
but after I got all the information it's
like well that Amendment would have hurt
people more than help people and so I
just trashed it
I believe that this system works I
believe that once it's automated it's
going to be better
I can't speak to corruption there are
problems in all areas of our society
but I think the system works I think it
works well and once it's automated
representative Ames
Ames oops I just want to uh thank the
representative for um
doing a thorough job and making it
easier for the rest of us thank you
thank you very much
representative Platt yeah the one
concern I walked away with is the public
hearing I think you've addressed
which was whether the penalty was
proportionate with the level of uh a
mildew but after all that length of time
several notices they get and it's only
50 bucks I don't see that at all and so
I think this this week this bill should
be itl period thank you thank you for
making that point I agree that's what I
I thought after five notices
spanning at least 150 days a fifty
dollar fine
it's it's like nothing considering the
amount of time that's been wasted
tracking this thing and to think that
the second level find is only a hundred
dollars I mean if they ever got the 500
or a thousand they earned it
well I think it was also a discussion if
I remember I can read my notes was the
proportionality right losing someone's
ability to register their vehicle is
seems harsh was the other thing I
remembered representative El Booker
thank you madam chair I agree but
um the information
that representative orrs has gotten us
not only talks about the fines but that
um there are usually 10 violations that
have happened before so we're not
talking about oh I forgot to put my
transponder on the car oops my bad it
was I chose to not do it at least 10
times uh even after I noticed it the
first one
um I
you know corruption occurs everywhere in
life you know there's always there are
bad people in every profession I have no
doubt about that
I think though that this system works
and
um
doing anything with this bill other than
itl in my mind is a bad idea
representative ulery and oh I'm sorry I
apologize representative had his hand up
I apologize thank you um
so the issue I just so I get it I mean
it's not the one-time offense that
you're going to lose your ability to
register your cards 10.
but you think about times 10 times back
and forth the Callahan tunnel it's two
dollars and five cents one way so you
know you go back to Logan five times and
yes there could be intentional right
but to violate something in
Massachusetts for twenty dollars and
fifty cents and granted you're ignoring
the whatever uh subsequent notices
and losing the privilege to drive in New
Hampshire for something that occurs in
Massachusetts that's my hang up on it I
don't I don't think that
were they intentional absolutely at that
point right I mean are they ignoring the
the fines yes
but I the you know we're not talking
about a public safety issue we're not
talking about somebody drunk driving
putting people's lives in danger we're
skipping out on a toll that happened in
another state that's the part that I am
struggling with is that
I don't think again I don't think the
punishment fits the crime and you know
fully admitted driving is a privilege
you're ignoring things I just
acknowledge everything that you're
saying
but to say that it doesn't rise to the
level of the inability to register your
car
that's where I'm stuck on and I and I I
don't see it that way I mean I I think
there may be some workarounds we could
probably work through this but I I don't
see it it rises to that level Something
committing in something another state
yeah so thank you very much for making
that point uh first of all I absolutely
agree with you uh second of all full
disclosure we had lunch together and he
bought my lunch so I got to be careful
no I'm just kidding
see you're still paying attention that's
good so uh representative I do agree
with you however it's not just the the
ten tolls right in and out five times so
after the ten tolls they got 30 days to
respond to paying that toll then if they
never ran another toll booth they got
another 30 days and then if they haven't
run another toll booth they got in their
30 days
and then if they haven't run yeah well
that happens five times so all I'm
saying is after 120 days that starts the
clock where eventually if they don't pay
they're going to get dinged and even
with that if they walked in and paid
it would go away and and the and the
worst they would have to do is pay their
tolls and fifty dollars and and what we
see in our society is
the person that's habitually picked up
for having a headlight out or they their
car is uninspected it's usually
a chain of events that's going on like
the person that was picked up just
recently just read it and the conquered
paper where they were picked up for
having they were pulled over for having
a shattered windshield and they're
driving around well they had they didn't
have a license I don't believe no
suspense no uh registration yeah but
they let me go yeah and
charges and I'm like and all it was was
a broken windshield so I'm saying the
person that's going to habitually run
these tolls and the pattern is if you
looked at the spreadsheet in there I
mean we're talking thousands some of
these people I mean you had the big ones
up and you're talking thousands of
violations so at at what point even if
they did it in Massachusetts I don't
care if they did in Massachusetts New
Hampshire Maine it doesn't matter to me
I mean this is an irresponsible person
that doesn't give a
who thank you all right I see lots of
hands up so what I'd like to do is start
in this corner and work my way all the
way around that way everyone gets a
chance anything else representative
right now representative fellows did you
have anything to question or add on this
discussion
okay I think we should I TL that bill
okay and moving along to representative
chamber did you have your hand up no
representative ulery yeah what uh two
quick comments uh for the committee
DLT has been before criminal justice and
the house dot committee and before both
of those committees where I was sitting
in
they said we're not bill collectors we
don't have anything to do with bill
collecting we have no system in place to
do bill collection and now you're
telling us they do have a system so
either they were lying them or they're
lying to you sir well I I think we have
a little bit of a
disconnect there D.O.T is not a bill
collector DMV does collect money it's
DMV that's driving this
okay representative uh wait Jay James
you didn't have any representative all
me
uh I do we're not
just talking about people that aren't
paying attention and don't want to pay
in particular what we're talking about
is the Integrity of the turnpike fund
and the ability of the turnpike fund to
pay for the turnpike to continue to
operate
and if we
if we make it known to the people of
Massachusetts that they can come here
and go scot-free
by not paying our tolls
which a lot of them do come into the
southern part of the State uh and
through towards Maine then
there are going to be a lot more of them
not paying their tolls I guarantee you I
got a lot of Massachusetts relatives
in full disclosure okay representative
plan I think uh representative Almy just
said what I'm going to say is different
words but this is a three-state
agreement reciprocal agreement so yes we
may be suspending New Hampshire licenses
for uh for uh tolls old in Massachusetts
but the opposite is also true
Massachusetts driver's licenses get
suspended uh registrations get suspended
when they're not paying New Hampshire
tolls and I think that benefits New
Hampshire a whole bunch more than Mass
just because of the number of of
southern people coming up here into our
state you know I'm from the
Massachusetts originally myself
I moved when I was nine so forgive me
okay other comments hands over here
representative Doucet anything well
representative so I have to say that uh
thank you madam chair but um you just
took the words out of my mouth
you son of a so um but I also it's more
than a three-state agreement though I
think it was like you know Connecticut
Vermont Rhode Island New York and New
Jersey that's correct so um yeah I think
it would be the other states are
insignificant in terms of materiality
it's 1.3 percent I believe so but you're
right it is the other states too and
they're and they're listed in your
paperwork
thank you
okay representatively not to put you on
the spot but we're kind of going around
the room just to get us okay good
representative soti any thoughts
representative Elber anything else good
okay
um
all right well good discussion we're not
taking a vote or anything yet maybe we
have something we can deal with tomorrow
at our exec session
I'm gonna think about I don't know
okay all right guys phew another big day
thank you very much we'll see you here
tomorrow at 1 15.
and we'll see what we can get done
and if we can the things that we get
done if we can be prepared with whoever
makes the motion maybe have something
drafted up to so that we can you can
fine tune it we can hand it off to the
committee assistant that we can get more
stuff to the house clerk so he'll be
happy
great thank you
uh just to remind Republicans we'll be
caucusing tomorrow at 10 A.M
in some room on the floor third floor
300 something like that okay